there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey what's going on you guys it's
Wednesday night Tom's head is shining in
the evening no I'm just kidding
let me get your damn command modules set
up here okay yeah
I had to run in here man I feel like I'm
leaving the [ __ ] screen and going
where are you going to go to the next
video going into the other video you got
plenty of room what are you talking
about I don't know just look at all kind
of room over there look over there and
see my shoulder leaving with spot goes
this way okay
all right okay
so uh this is gonna be a good show
tonight we hadn't done a UFO show in a
while yeah like and usually like doing
those so this is one that you kind of
have a little bit of a personal
connection with connection to this and
so we had been wanting to do this one
for a while so it finally won in the
poll yeah you know what I mean so we
finally got around to doing it the
Lonnie Zamora case yeah and uh
Lonnie zamor I think is Lonnie samori
Lani Zamora Jr I think is what his name
is or is it isn't that isn't that what
his name is Lonnie Zamora Jr I don't
know I think there's any uh something it
might be
his son was my squad leader in Korea and
the first in the 506.
and
I remember I was down
um
um
Collier guard post Collier right up on
the DMZ
and uh
I was down in the little NCO bunker that
they had down there near where they
where they stored all the dam explosives
and the rockets and everything were down
in there and that's where the ncos slept
and he had me doing some kind of Duty
down there forgot what it was
but I was sleeping on the floor in there
and I could overhear him talking to the
guy next to him
it was another NCO about this case he
goes your dad he he goes I heard your
dad was the one that saw that UFO he
goes yeah
and I sat there for probably about two
or three hours and heard him
talk about this and answer a bunch of
questions I remembered a lot of it I
remember a lot of details and I at the
time I vaguely knew the case when he
when he said it looked like an egg and
stuff yeah and that that it was a it was
a cop down I think in New Mexico I think
yeah it's New Mexico Mexico yeah
and uh I'd seen a documentary on it and
I was like oh yeah Zamora Zamora sent
you same guy
now he kind of looked like his dad in a
way but his dad looked kind of short and
stocky
Sergeant Zamora was pretty big
um
Well everybody's big for my point of
view he's probably about five nine five
ten yeah yeah same yeah
everybody's big to me because I'm a
small person yeah 5 10.
and it was just kind of a
New Mexican Indian kind of guy he had an
Indian kind of an idiot hey yeah Ross
what are you doing you [ __ ] up go
ahead give me give me give me some
push-ups yeah you talk like that you
know
and I said something to him one time and
his team there says don't you dare talk
to him you want to talk to him you got
to go through me if you gonna talk to
him you need to use [ __ ] smoke
signals I'll never [ __ ] remember that
[ __ ] because everybody started falling
out and busted up talking to him if you
want to talk to him you got to use smoke
signals that's what he [ __ ] say
hey his team leader was uh who's like
his the guy right underneath him
steam leader was like from [ __ ]
Tennessee or something you know [ __ ] it
was just it was two opposites a little
bitty white dude [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
Bulldog or this big chilled out [ __ ]
Indian guy who's like kind of like Chief
from uh
the Cuckoo's Nest yeah but I heard him
tell this story and um yeah it was a
pretty good story I I could add to it
because uh I've never heard
I've never heard any of what he said in
any of the uh
documentaries
yeah there's got I've got like some I
found like a really good um breakdown of
the case and uh it had like some quotes
from there and I was watching like a
couple documentaries about it that had
like some recordings of his original
uh you know interviews in there
so yeah so we'll get into and like I
said if if I say something because like
I said I you know you might be more
familiar with the case than me so if I
you know say something that you don't
that that doesn't mind that doesn't line
up then like the story's gone through so
many hands
you know what I mean it stuff has been
added to it and a lot of stuff got left
out
but we'll talk about it more towards the
end it'll make more sense I think if I
talk about it
towards the end some of the stuff that
was left out I remember sergeant and I
don't remember what
we weren't on first name basis with
Sergeant Zamora you know I was pretty
new when I was in his Squad
and he ended up leaving about when I was
probably about four or five months maybe
six months into my Tour on Korea I might
have only been about four months but
when you're young and you're in that
[ __ ] four months seems like a
lifetime
and um
he left and I I think his first name was
also Lonnie I think
I mean that would make sense I think his
name now Lonnie's more the guy that saw
the UFO he died in 2009 I think
so I need some more passed away a while
back so his dad was still alive up until
2009 yeah okay in 2009. all right
but uh yeah I I first became aware of
this game it's weird because I guess
this is kind of like a big case in UFO
circles but you don't hear about it as
much as you hear about like some of the
other ones like the you know the black
triangles and Roswell and all that kind
of [ __ ] but I don't know like I first
heard of this case I think it was on
Unsolved Mysteries yeah I saw it on
Unsolved Mysteries and uh then after
that like I kind of forgot about it and
then but the more I looked into it I was
like yeah there is kind of like a lot of
stuff about this because it is seen I
guess in UFO circles it's kind of
considered like one of the more credible
ones yeah you know what I mean
yeah this happened
yeah if you saw something it's just you
know the there's a lot of physical
evidence this question is like what was
it like you know it's not necessarily
means that it was extraterrestrial right
and I did see something and I got a
little bit of inside from his son
of what Zamora what what officers Zamora
thought it was
there was Intelligence agents there
during his uh interrogation and also
during his press release which we'll
probably get into that I don't know if
he was FBI or CIA or something he'd been
a long time since I'd heard it but there
was
he wasn't alone doing this and that he
had at the time he started to do press
releases he had a a Handler with him
yeah and that Handler kind of controlled
what he was saying and a couple times he
said that outright because I heard like
a snippet of an interview with him where
he basically said oh well they told me
I'm not supposed to say about that yeah
I have a little bit information about
that yeah yeah that's good because like
I said I don't have a huge amount but
they did tell him like not to say Sir
yeah yeah Sergeant Zamora said some
stuff about it because you see back in
those days there was no internet
so you could say something to people
around you and it would never really go
public but he told me some stuff what
his dad said
okay yeah
Spock holladoc says love these episodes
guys thank you oh also I've always loved
y'all's setup the place looks legendary
Oh thanks thank you yeah it actually
looks cooler over there she's got some
really expensive dark red curtains look
like something about a damn Dracula's
castle
[Laughter]
this is my office yeah yeah and then I
got like a candelabra and everything we
had to make a video do a tour in here
and show them what it looks like yeah
because I kind of that's actually a good
idea maybe I can do it like maybe I
could put it on uh patreon or I could
put a regular site or just drop it in
here I guess yeah because there's like
so much stuff like you can see a lot of
the stuff and like when people send us
gifts and things like that we try to you
know like my Tom savini picture and all
my cool Mexican skulls and all that kind
of stuff Museum in here it is but it's
like you know and and and Dennis back
there BTK that's Sophie said yeah um but
yes gargoyles and Egyptian stuff and
computers and books and
Day of the Dead stuff from Mexico and a
couch over there with a black couch and
that pookies she actually hasn't torn up
the couch she's torn up the Ottomans
though for some reason she never tears
the couch up she just likes to jump on
the ottoman or like get on the side of
the autumn in a tear she's torn all the
stuffing out and it was new like I
bought it new like last year and she's
already like torn it all up oh well what
are you gonna do she's a kitty Kitty's
gonna Kitty you know what I mean yeah
but yeah so we should probably do that
so you can see some of this stuff like
more close up even though it's kind of
well I don't think I'm just put a mess
in here it's just you know there's a lot
of stuff and it's just like cramping a
little all these little kind of corners
and everything
but yeah so uh ever I guess everybody
seems excited about doing the UFO show
like I said we don't do them that often
I can't remember the last time we did a
UFO yeah I like UFO stuff I know you do
I know you do you do well yeah hey
there's
turns out recently they're saying that
yeah the the military and the government
the intelligence agencies have been
taking this seriously for a long time
that it's a real phenomenon now was this
extraterrestrial we're going to get into
it we're gonna get into it
yeah I'm not really sure where I stand
on this one I mean to me I kind of feel
like I don't know let's get into it I
know where I stand on it you do yep I'm
I'm ambivalent I'm not really sure I'm
not really sure
but yeah so um interestingly this
happened in New Mexico and I kind of
feel like Roswell New Mexico is the one
that gets all the [ __ ] publicity and
has a whole I mean the whole town of
Roswell is like alien Central right like
it's now a tourist trap and everything
like that but the thing about it well
that happened before this that happened
in 1947
but the whole Roswell case didn't really
get any cultural traction until probably
like the 1970s right I kind of feel like
it didn't really get really well known
until then yeah
but this case here uh also happened in
New Mexico was actually in Socorro New
Mexico and this happened in
1964. so after Roswell but before
Roswell became like Roswell like when I
was born so it's not as far back as I
thought it was so yeah in 1964. so he'd
still be alive his dad yeah yeah like I
said his dad just died in 2000 well just
that was like 11 years ago but so yeah
and I always think I always think of his
son as being much older than me looking
back on he's probably three years older
than me yeah but you know what I mean
they're four maybe
so no maybe five but yeah probably about
five years well I don't know but that
seems like somebody who's way older than
you when you're yeah 20 you know 20
years old 21.
Zach says uh did you hear they
identified the boy in the box with the
DNA genealogy today holy [ __ ] no I
didn't actually it's a it's an unsolved
murder case like a really famous
unsolved murder case actually matter of
fact I think that I did a post on my
crime and Memorial site about it so now
I'm gonna have to go in there and update
it if they've done that but yeah I
didn't hear that today I was like doing
other stuff and didn't like read
anything I think all those Killers out
there [ __ ] shaking in their boots
yeah that's what I mean it's like
they're solving it's crazy like because
now every time like if I post something
on my site like from my book I always
have to check and make sure and some of
them actually have been solved like in
the just in a couple of years since I
wrote the book you know what I mean
including boy in the box but that's like
an older case though all those uh
all those bodies dudes like Bundy just
left out in the woods never found ever
yeah and what was funny is that
I ended up
I ended up uh reading or hearing later
on that the ones that were
least likely to be found ones that were
just left on the surface out in the
wooded area
yeah I mean if you buried it actually
they'd find it yeah but if you just left
it out they didn't find them the animals
got them yeah scattered it just [ __ ]
up but that's what happened yeah animals
don't know any better oh no there's
really okay food yeah you know you're
just food for somebody yeah you're just
another animal yeah
but yeah so uh so this case happened in
April of 1964.
so it's about quarter to six uh on April
24th
so you got a police officer Sergeant
Lonnie Zamora now he's in the middle of
like a high speed chase he's chasing a
speeder essentially
um kind of going down this highway that
goes through Socorro New Mexico
while he's
the car like kind of off to the side or
like a kind of a far distance in front
of him
he said that he heard a roar
and then saw like a flame in the sky
that he said was about half a mile a
mile away approximately
now he's wondering he said it was so
unusual that he actually
um you know kind of left off the the car
chase that he was doing and wanted to go
check it out because it's like it could
be you know a plane crash it could be a
car crash it could be an explosion like
he thought maybe it was an explosion at
first as well
um because there were some storage
Shacks of dynamite out there that might
have blown up so he's like well I better
go check this out no so he did like
radio in and say I saw something weird
like an explosion or something so I'm
gonna go like check it out
um so he did see like after this initial
weird flame that he saw in the sky he
saw what he called a quote-unquote
bluish orange flame and it was kind of
like descending like toward the ground
and he also said that it looked
funnel-like that's what he said the
shape was of the flame yeah yeah now
because he was kind of like driving at
the time like driving over to where it
was and was trying and was and was
trying to like look at the thing that
was sort of Landing or whatever at the
same time like while he was trying to
drive so he couldn't get that good a
look at it
um but he said that as he was driving
toward whatever this thing was he
realized that the sound that he had
heard was still audible he said it
didn't sound like an explosion like a
blasting kind of noise he said it
sounded like a roar that's what it
sounded like a continuous sound like
that now he said he heard this noise for
a few more seconds
um and then like it went like from a
high pitched Roar to a low pitched Roar
now so the object's leg keeps going
lower
um you know and Lonnie Zamora is kind of
coming up a hill like in his car was
kind of having a hard time you know
getting up the hill or whatever and then
by the time he got kind of the top of
the hill like the guy he was chasing
like you know got away he was probably
like woo you know like it was his lucky
day he could just keep speeding or
whatever
um and at this point the noise uh had
stopped
so Lonnie keeps going
and then he said that he saw like a shot
something shining on the side of the
road like a shiny object around 200
yards ahead of him
now at first he thought his initial
thought was that it was an overturned
car like because he didn't you know it
was still like at some distance away
and he said that he could see what he
thought was two people standing next to
the thing uh like they were examining
the vehicle almost like like I said it
had been overturned or somebody been in
an accident and they were like checking
it out
now he said that one of the people
seemed to notice that he was coming
and uh kind of like look toward him he
said both of the people had like white
coveralls on
he said he didn't notice anything
unusual about them other than their size
he said that they looked like large kids
or small adults so you know he said like
they looked like humans but they were
just like smaller than normal that's
about the only thing that he noticed
that was weird like short guys too short
guys in white coveralls
now um as he starts to get closer he
starts to realize that uh what he at
first thought was an overturned car is
not an overturned car
he said it looked like an O shape or an
egg shape and that it was he said it
looked like it was made of aluminum and
that it was like kind of like an
off-white or whitish kind of color
he also said that he saw some kind of
like red like Insignia or like a symbol
on one side of the craft I think he
would later describe it as kind of like
an umbrella shape on top with like an
arrow pointing upward and then like a
horizontal line underneath he said it
looks really weird like nothing like
he'd ever seen before yeah and I
I'm gonna chime in if I remember
correctly he came out later and he said
that he saw originally he said that he
saw the shape and he told some cops and
they remembered with the insignia
and when
an intelligence agent got involved in
that they told him to not say that
anymore yeah and come up with it that
was the main thing that they didn't
really want him you know I'm talking
about where the symbol really looked so
it didn't look the way he described it
looked like something else
and Zamora my my uh squad leader I
remembered vaguely what he said the
shape really was we'll talk about it
okay yeah when we answer that like
whenever
because I just remember they because if
you see like a documentary about it or
something like that it usually has I've
seen a couple different iterations of it
but at least the thing about
officer Zamora this is the same for his
son too they were real patriotic
real Kana
they were policemen it came from police
and military and government functionary
type backgrounds they really like
respected the government Law and Order
and uh honor they were real honorable
family
if the government told you to shut your
mouth and change it because National
Security you do it that's the way they
were
and as far as what I I vaguely remember
sergeants Memorial my squad leaders
saying he never I don't think his dad
ever told him what the symbol actually
was just described kind of what it would
look what it looked like
he said we'll get to it a bunch of lines
a bunch of lines yeah I've heard that
description as well I think that came
out a bit later yeah it was a bunch of
lines and and uh
we'll get into what what what what he
probably what it probably was on the
side but uh okay okay Dave is here hey
it says hello you two happy last day of
November yeah it's my sister's birthday
today so happy birthday Amanda I'm gonna
go see her this Sunday so actually we're
we won't get we won't be doing a matinee
show on Sunday because I will be going
to my sister's uh birthday dinner so you
know
I'll remind you all again anyway
um but yeah but today is actually her
birthday she's just not down here yet
so um so yeah so he radioed to dispatch
and said where he was and said what the
situation was
so he Parks the police car and gets out
and like starts to approach this
whatever it is
now he said that almost as soon as he
got out of the car uh that roaring sound
came back
and there was like a blue flame like
shooting out of the underside of this
egg-shaped whatever this was
now he thought it was going to maybe
blow up I mean he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] this is right so he basically like
hits the dirt right as you would
um so then like he kind of like goes
back to his car try kind of backing away
I guess like trying to get back to the
car like while still watching like
whatever the hell is going
now he said that the roar started
getting just louder and louder
um and it was rising in frequency going
from a lower pitch to a higher pitch
and then he said it's it went up in the
air like directly upward like that
and he said there was like the blue
flame with kind of like orange tinges
around the edges like underneath it
now he said at this point he could very
clearly see that it was like an egg
shape
because he was like really close to it
and he could still see the red like
symbol on the side of the thing and he
said that it looked like he didn't see
any doors or Windows like everything
looked really smooth like you couldn't
see any rivets or anything like that
basically and I was thinking to myself I
was like like
I guess it's like Mork and Mindy it
looked like mork's [ __ ] well wasn't
mork's ship like an actual egg
yeah I think it was smaller this is
bigger though yeah I'm pretty sure he
said it had legs on it
yeah that's the thing that's another
thing is that
they were asking him about the legs and
I've heard like two different so it's
like some of the stuff said he didn't
say that he saw legs but then some of
the reenactments I've seen and then some
of the other like sources that I read
said that he said that there was legs
there's either four legs or it's like
four main legs and like four more
smaller ones so like eight legs in total
like pretty much because I remember
miles and more Sergeant Moore said that
it had legs on it and it was four from
what I remember
yeah four no
it may have four other things but they
weren't legs they might have been a
little
antenna Spike type things yeah I think
that comes out through the box I think
that was the implication yeah the four
ones were the main or little veins or
something right
but it was four legs with
round pads
circular pads on them
so it didn't sink into the ground right
yeah
okay good yeah and then another thing
too because I remember like I heard a
snippet of an interview with him when
they were asking about landing gear yeah
and he said like because they were
asking him well when it took off like
did the legs like you know retract back
into the thing or what and he said that
he wasn't really looking at it at that
point so he wasn't really sure
so I guess that he did that it did have
legs but yeah that was
but it was like four main legs I think
the the kind of overarching thing was it
had four main legs and then maybe like
four smaller things like you said they
were just kind of like Spike stickers
fits what
my sergeant Zamora told me so far okay
and based on what he said
they thought it was the legs wouldn't
have didn't retract they were out the
whole time
but yeah I was just watching like a
reenactment of it where they had an
animation and they very clearly showed
the legs retracting and I was like I'm
pretty sure that like she didn't say
that like he said that he didn't see
what happened with the if there was
landing gear it was egg shaped it had
four legs on it with round landing gear
and there were two guys in it wearing
white flight suits pretty much yeah it
had a symbol on the side
although we don't know what the symbol
was
the the symbol that he gives an umbrella
thing with a
arrow that was a cover story and it
probably wasn't red it was probably
black
the black symbol
according to my songs or more it was a
series of lines
it has a use has a use I'll get it to it
okay that's that'll be interesting
because I haven't seen about anything
about that
um Zach says by the way Jenny I sent you
some notes for that story idea I had
yeah I saw that I just haven't had time
to read it yet because I got like really
behind again
I'm always behind
but you know what I mean I'll get to it
like tomorrow I promise or I'll try to
I'll try to
um okay so okay so it starts like going
up like I said and then he said when it
was about 20 feet off the ground it
stopped and like hovered there for a few
seconds
so at this point
um Lonnie's try starting to freak out a
little bit like I guess as you would
and he's basically like well he doesn't
know what's gonna happen now like or
more Flames gonna come out or you know
something so they said he covered his
face up he said he covered his face up
with his arms which is probably why he
didn't see anything like with landing
gear or whatever so he said when he took
his arm away
that the thing was moving in a straight
line like away from him but like really
fast he said that it was probably 10 to
15 feet off the ground
he said there was a dynamite Shack like
right by it and it went over it and it
was about three feet over the roof no so
not high it was like still pretty low he
said it was very very fast and then it
seemed to like rise up and just take off
like and kind of he could still see it
for a while but it was going like really
really fast
so he runs back to his car that all
checks out with what yeah masamara said
yep and I think he said there was a car
on the road also saw it a couple saw it
across the road I think he said there
was there were some uh some other
Witnesses yeah I'm going to get into
that too I don't know I don't know if
that if I think I think it was him that
said that that there was another that
there was a some witnesses on a road
that saw it go over the road I'm pretty
sure I heard that from some more yeah
that's yeah that checks out um I'm gonna
get into that yeah because there were
other people that like corroborated yeah
he wasn't the only person that saw it
that saw it he was the only person that
saw it like close up right but he wasn't
the only person that saw it yeah I think
it was a man and a woman no it was two
guys two guys it was two guys it was
like tourists or something
um but that I've always been the only
thing but yeah yeah okay
um okay so he gets back to the car and
he radios the police desk and he tells
the guy
um hey look out the window and tell me
if you see anything like flying over
because I guess that was like the
general area
so he kept watching it and he said like
I said that he could still see it like
for a while as it was like going out
over like the canyon or whatever
now as soon as he couldn't see it
anymore there was another police officer
another sergeant Sam Chavez and he
showed up at the location because he'd
heard like the radio calls earlier he
said when he got there
um that Lonnie Zamora looked what he
called white as a plate I've also heard
white as a corpse but I don't know which
one of those is correct anyway he was
like super pale and he was like really
really shot he was in shock like clearly
like he was really scared
um now when they go and look at where
because he was like look there was this
thing was like right here
and they go to investigate the area and
they said that they called it um burning
brush quote unquote uh they said that
there was kind of smoke there was no
flames but there was kind of like smoke
coming up from this little area where
the thing had been sitting
um and then Chavez said that he saw what
appeared to be eight imprints like four
of the indentations were really big and
rectangular and like deeper while the
other four were like littler and round
yeah okay so four like big deep square
like rectangular ones and four like
yeah yeah that fits kind of what he told
me I thought they were round big round
ones but okay yeah square that that
worked too yeah yeah and then um so like
I said it's kind of like because I kind
of feel like Lonnie said at some points
that he hadn't noticed any legs or then
like later he did say you know it's like
I'm not really sure because I've heard
both things and like I said I didn't
interview the guy myself so I don't
really know I think it was legs
and then something kind of like
bent type of rebar thing that way if you
press down on the craft it wouldn't
bottom out on the bottom of the fuselage
it would bottom out on these you know
what I mean metal
L-shaped things it went down they were
kind of like fins but they're you know
something like that that way the bottom
of the craft wouldn't touch the ground
yeah so it sat on the sat on because you
know when something lands and it weighs
a lot
it's got to have a springy suspension
so you don't want the bottom of the
craft if there's nozzles down there to
make contact with the grounds you gotta
have guard around it you know what I'm
talking about yeah so that's what that's
what happened it it landed and it those
little guards bottomed out on the ground
when it landed that's why I left
indentations there
I'm kind of wondering now because I've
seen a couple different animations of
this like in different
um documentaries and stuff and in some
of the
reenactments the craft is like an egg on
its side yeah like that but then in one
reenactment I was watching earlier was
like that yeah it was pointed up
so I didn't know which way was correct
because he didn't really specify because
I think if it was me if I saw the [ __ ]
I'd be like oh it was like an egg
standing upright or it was like an egg
like on its side you know what I mean no
from what I remember what mazzamora said
it was standing straight up like an egg
and it had legs on the bottom of it okay
so so that means that the reenactment
that I just watched on quest which was
like 12 or 13 minutes off was correct
because they had the egg yeah upright
like that basically a rocket yeah what
you describing is like an egg-shaped
rocket
with legs
egg with legs yeah okay
okay so uh so the incident kind of uh
pretty much hours later like uh the
Press got wind of it and then a few days
later pretty much like all the UFO
researchers and all the you know
Associated Press and all that stuff kind
of descended on Socorro to check this
out because you know what I mean every
time there's like a UFO sighting or
something like that you also had groups
like the uh aerial phenomena research
organization National investigations
committee on aerial phenomena all those
kind of people they also came out and
also the Air Force would send out uh
representatives from Project Blue Book
to do an official investigation
now one of the first people to show up
was a guy from uh the national
investigations committee on
aerofenomenon nycap and his name is Ray
Stanford
now he actually kind of got to talk to a
lot of the witnesses like before the
story like got really really big like
before it went like National or whatever
now he actually found a person who had
been driving through the area like I
said it was actually two people who had
been driving through the area and he
actually found that person all kind of
talk about them in a minute
um but there was also another
corroborating report
there was a person who had called a TV
station in Albuquerque
at 5 30 p.m which was about 15 minutes
before uh you know before Lonnie Zamora
had his sighting and at 5 30 PM this
person in Albuquerque called the TV
station and said that they saw an oval
object flying at low altitude and very
very slowly
um heading towards Socorro so that's
somebody else that saw it like heading
toward that area like and this was
before
um you know anybody had heard anything
about it
um there were also a bunch of witnesses
that came forward and said that they had
heard that corroborated like uh the loud
roaring sound uh that they had heard the
sound at the same time that Lonnie's
more claimed that he had heard it and a
couple of them heard the second Roar as
well because like I said it roared two
times
um and they also had they also
discovered that there had been three
reports
um of people who had called the police
and reported a bright glowing object
like rising up into the sky so there
were three separate reports of that from
that same night and again those all
reports were received before
um anything you know had gotten really
like public or anything like that
there was also somebody that had
reported something from La Madeira in
New Mexico
and the FBI actually went out and
checked out that one on the same day
that this uh that the Zamora incident
occurred somebody else in that section
of New Mexico reported a UFO
and they never did figure out uh what
that was like they reported some kind of
weird craft and they couldn't figure out
what it was
now
um also two days after the Lonnie Zamora
incident on April 26th at about one in
the morning
um a resident around there would hear
they heard all their horses like kind of
being all like what the [ __ ] like making
all kind of weird noises and stuff and
he went out to see what was going on and
he saw something that he described as
shaped like a butane tank landing on the
ground so that was kind of like uh
nearby and then he said he saw it take
off and it had blue white flames on the
underside and that he also found four
indentations on the ground and like for
smaller ones inside just like Lonnie
Zamora had reported and there was also a
circular patch of ground that was burned
like where the landing site had been and
it stayed like that for quite a while
and they don't mention any smoke do they
uh yeah they did they did they said
there was no flames but that like some
of the stuff was like smoking no I'm
saying when it's flying in the air it's
not leaving a trail of smoke oh nobody
said anything about God I don't think
all right slasher Fred said sounds like
an Unsolved Mysteries episode this uh
this was this was on Unsolved Mystery it
was a long time ago I don't remember
what season it was or what year it was
but that was when I first heard about it
lack of smoke tells me something we'll
talk about it later well you can talk
about it now if you want to while I take
a drink
all I can say is uh whatever kind of
combustion that is it's real clean and
it's not t-saw it's teased off and see
stuff which was a normal
1940s 1950s hypergolic rocket fuel left
a lot of smoke behind well it wasn't
smoke it's more like water vapor you
know I think it was more water vapor
than anything else so whatever it is
it's burning real clean
okay
but the roaring sound that checks out
with a rocket
yeah yeah
I'm pretty sure I know what it is and I
think Lonnie Zamora
late senior later on or Junior
um because I don't know I think
my zamoras I think his dad was a junior
which would have meant that that
mizamore was the third I think yeah
because I think his name was Lonnie also
Bert Jr Jr never been the third Lonnie
III yeah junior junior
and he told he told everybody what they
kind of thought it was eventually based
on everything but that's I've never
that's never heard it in the public
sphere because there's um
there's incentive to
to keep the story
exciting you know it's still exciting
what it what it was
okay go ahead
yeah so remember how we said earlier
that there were two people that have
been passing through the area that also
saw the [ __ ]
um yeah they found out like who that was
later on what ended up happening was
that there was a guy named opal grinder
I can't believe that's that dude's real
name but he owned a a gas station which
I think was Whiting brothers wedding
Brothers I'm not really sure how you
pronounced it but it was a gas station
near where you know the whole incident
took place
and while the Air Force was
investigating they interviewed him and
he said I didn't see the ship myself
personally but there was these two dudes
who stopped to get gas and they said
they had seen it so like they talked to
him about it they said that um
that they had been they had heard like
the loud booming sound or the Roaring
and then like one of the guys from the
car like came in to pay for the stuff
like into the gas station and he says to
the guy that owns the place he's like
wow your air your aircraft fly really
low around here or something like that
and opal opal says um yeah a lot of we
have a lot of helicopters around here I
mean it's it's right near White Sands
you know
um he's like yeah we have a lot of
helicopters around here and the guy said
it was a funny looking helicopter if
that's what it was
and then so they ended up finding these
two guys uh their names were Larry
kratzner and uh that was the guy that
had gone inside and his friend whose
name was Paul keys or Kai's I'm not
really sure they were actually from
Dubuque in Iowa and they were uh driving
back there at the time because they were
like on vacation so they got interviewed
in 1978
and a lot of their [ __ ] like lined up
with uh Lonnie Zamora's uh stuff and one
of them said the guy that went in the
store he said um and this is a quote I
saw a cloud of black smoke coming from
the ground uh ahead of I guess ahead of
us and to the right I could see a round
saucer or egg-shaped object ascending
vertically from the black smoke okay so
it did have smoke on that's what he said
okay so so he saw it too all right now
he actually said that he could see
windows on the side of the object which
actually Lonnie said that he didn't see
a doors or Windows yeah
um but this guy also said that he saw a
red Z on the side of it like a like
something that looked like a z and it
was red yeah so that's like another
corroborating okay yeah
it's not quite a z though more like a I
don't I don't want to say it almost like
a swastika or a lines you know German
Cross you have like a cross shape thing
yeah and then you have almost kind of
like two h's inverted yeah almost like a
cross hair type thing right I got a
stadium yeah yeah yeah I know that's
what it was okay I know what you're
talking about yeah
I know you're talking about but the
thing about it is that if I mean if it
was weird looking and you just saw it
for like a couple seconds like you
wouldn't necessarily right you know
something would just like you know
imprint itself in your brain like oh it
kind of looked like a z but not like
that you know what I mean more kind of
like a Crosshair or two H is impo
superimposed almost kind of like in a
swastika fashion you know how like a
swastika's more like two Z's right
imagine if it was two h's like an X with
a box a kind of a box around it with an
X but they didn't connect and then lines
vertical lines Stadium Alliance is what
you're talking about all right I'll go
ahead and say it now yeah
it's the kind of Stadium lines you put
on some kind of a test craft
when you're using high speed cameras and
and uh what do you with telescopes so
you can um get a pretty accurate because
inside that inside that telescopic
camera there's a bunch of lines in there
will help you estimate how far away the
camera it is which will help you to
figure out how fast it's moving yeah
because they didn't have
GPS back then yeah they had to do it
yeah
what we're talking about is a [ __ ]
test craft
okay it's a rocket
vertical takeoff and landing in the 60s
some kind of like the lunar lander
in it with a fuselage and windows around
it well spoiler alert that is one of the
uh explanations yeah it's probably what
it was probably what it was yeah but um
some contractor made it making this
thing and got out of hand they were very
dangerous dudes got killed that's
confirmed that they made things like
that
to test the lunar lander and then to try
to get some skills on how to control
these things for the flight surfaces and
stuff and dudes got killed famous test
pies got killed testing craft like that
it wasn't just one there must have been
a bunch of them
because maybe they thought there were
other applications besides space travel
you know because you
one of the priorities in
jet combat was vertical landing and
takeoff because they thought in atomic
war you'd be able to destroy enemy
uh runways
so you wanted a high performance
aircraft that could just sit on the
ground take off and then land on their
tail
they were working on that you had to be
some kind of a jet
but Jets were real complicated at that
time and
it requires a lot to make a jet so they
were also experimenting with rockets
which rockets rocketry and jets were the
same thing if you go back far enough
you know a lot of times they would just
call they would call a rocket a jet and
that's jet powered and it's actually
rocket powered you know and sometimes
they would refer to a jet as a rocket
and a rocket as a jet it just anything
that's shooting something out of the
back they'd call it a rocket or a jet
it wasn't until later when you're
talking about compressor blades and fuel
injection and
but one of the most simple ones like a
hypergalic rocket engine like out of the
measurement me163 comet you just mix
pure hydrogen peroxide and pure I forgot
what the other thing [ __ ] was
very dangerous [ __ ] chemicals and
they [ __ ] explode like crazy out of a
little 40 or 50 pound [ __ ]
I think it was cast iron rocket
and it's just valves and you'll get
thousands and thousands of pounds of
Thrust out of that [ __ ] it'd burn up
fuel fast but lots and lots of power
out of some without any moving Parts
made out of junk
so
the incentive was to make some kind of
rocket with vertical leading and take
off like a shoot down jet
or incoming bombers and stuff sounds
like something like that it sounds like
a test vehicle for something like that
perhaps so probably
and I think you're giving the story so
far the modern audience [ __ ] already
knows it's making smoke and it's making
a [ __ ] ton of noise and everybody's
seeing it they got little dudes and
Suits coming out of it it's got windows
on the side little dudes yeah yeah this
is not
this is not alien technology
no that's 60s technology
Jetson's [ __ ]
is exactly what that is
yeah this is what's kind of interesting
to me so the military shows up
um the day after the incident like to
interview Lonnie Zamora and others so
the main guy that came uh you got your
army Captain Richard holder he was like
the the guy that was coming from like
White Sands and then you had a guy from
the FBI whose name was Arthur Bynes so
they interview Lonnie Zamora
interestingly Lonnie Zamora did not
think did not say that it was an alien
spacecraft he thought that it was a
secret experimental craft that's what he
said in the interview yeah and that's
what that's what my but the thing about
it though was that the art that that
holder said
um no no that's not what it is
um and he's basically like we don't have
anything like that yeah so it's almost
like Zamora was saying yeah I'm pretty
sure it was like a secret experimental
oh no it's not dead oh no it's not yeah
it's not that it's a it's a UFO it was
aliens yeah it's aliens
how that went yeah that's just that's
how that's supposedly that's the same
thing that my squad leader
Zamora said
he said he said my dad didn't think he
was a UFO he said he said it would look
man-made
you know
and they they told him to you know go oh
no we're going with the UFO story you
want to help out America you know and so
he was
Lonnie Zamora
officer Lonnie Zamora went along with
this out of patriotism
the cover story
so and man he just like got made fun of
him and [ __ ] like that all the time it
was kind of sad like after
yeah uh James Knapp said Tom knew his
son yeah yeah he was my his son was my
squad leader in Korea yeah I heard the
story right from his mouth
Sergeant Zamora and I didn't know the
case that well I just remembered you
know what he was saying was ringing a
bell
and uh and and the guy he was talking to
was another NCO and he goes that was
your dad and he's like yeah it was my
dad he knew the case a lot better than I
did it because it was legendary these
guys are a little bit older than me
about four or five years older so so you
know it was famous to them to me it was
just like something you saw an Unsolved
Mysteries you know and I heard about it
a couple times
but Sergeant Zamora said to his dad said
it was a test craft
yeah well like I said that checks out
with what I with the the thing that I
read yeah they said during the first
interview with the military he said he
thought it was a secret test drive he
didn't say he thought it was aliens hmm
and they told him we going with the
alien story yeah pretty much it's like I
don't know if they said that outright
but that was kind of like
according to my to my sergeant Zamora
they were kind of pushing him along
going come on you know you you're right
you know uh you're a good American you
know you you know you you want to help
out your country we're going to go with
this you know you you know that's it was
that kind of deal
and I think they rewarded him if I
remember correctly for going along with
it like they were cutting in checks oh I
don't know yeah well they were paying
him for his time yeah okay so that's the
same thing cutting a check they should
pay him we're gonna pay you for your
time we're gonna make sure you're
compensated for your time to you know so
and he's helping the country and they're
paying him and he's they're paying him
to help cover up this research craft
you can say what's Government research
no I wasn't even government it was
you're talking about McDonald Douglas
and [ __ ] [ __ ] North Grumman and
it's those guys they were the
contractors but the government steps in
to protect the contractors they're
working together the military industrial
complex you know so he just kind of got
caught up in it
but even back when he was telling the
story and I was that guard post call
you're listening to it
shards more at no time said that it was
uh Alien yeah I don't think he ever did
like he didn't he said he didn't know
what it was and he thought it was weird
but he didn't think it was alien he
thought about my sergeant Zamora oh okay
he said his dad didn't think that it was
alien
said that it was some kind of testcraft
but that they didn't want him talking
about it because it had already gotten
out of the bag yeah by the time they got
there
so they were just trying to play cleanup
that's how they do yeah
disinformation
disinformation or misinformation I'm Ray
van Pier said have you all ever heard
about Jack Parsons the guy who invented
Rocket Fuel who was inspired by the
Kabbalah and other occult yes yeah we uh
did a show we did a show about him
actually that might have been the last
UFO kind of adjacent show that we did
was it it wasn't that long ago maybe a
year
I could so we were in this house so it
was sometime in the last year or so that
we did a show about Jack Parson I
remember Parsons I remember
yeah he was uh he was an interesting
dude
so uh so basically after they
interviewed Lonnie Zamora like the day
after the incident
um the funny thing in a lot of uh
documentaries as I pointed this out was
that uh holder and burns like Burns was
the FBI guy they would go to The Landing
location to check it out but they went
there in the dark and they only had
flashlights and then they went and like
cordoned off the area and like took a
bunch of samples and everything now a
couple of later
books and reports and stuff have claimed
that the reason they went in there was
because they wanted to take these
samples of fused sand like they said
that because like they said that it was
so hot that it fused the sand in the
glass
and uh so they went in there and like
took it so that nobody could see it like
when the sun came up you know what I
mean there's no proof of that happening
but that's kind of like the rumor that
was going around that they had taken
like this kind of fused sand glass from
like underneath where this where the
ship was and a couple people have kind
that kind of were in on it like knew
something about that but I don't know if
that's true or not
um so basically uh there was a guy who
came there like from Project to Blue
Book right uh whose name was Alan
heineck yeah and um yeah he came to
Socorro like four days after the
incident so he actually didn't show up
until April 28th
now when he got there like because I
think some people from the airport Air
Force had already been there and because
they were kind of like busting uh Lonnie
zamoras and Sam Chavez as chops like
saying oh we just think it's a hoax and
you guys are idiots or whatever they
were kind of being like jerks to them
so
um so Zamora and Chavez were a little
bit uh pissed off with the Air Force at
this point so like when Alan heinek
showed up they like at first they didn't
really want to talk to them because they
thought well you Air Force people have
really been douches to us like so far
like telling us that we're hoaxing or
that we just fell for a hoax or some
[ __ ] like that
so you know so it took him a while to
kind of like get them to talk to them
now uh basically it's kind of like
um I think Alan heineck when he got
there
I don't know if he was necessarily like
new what because the Air Force had
already been there I guess and
When Alan heineck got there he was like
I'm I think that the Air Force
he said it like he wrote later he said
the Air Force doesn't know what science
is
um
and I mean because high neck actually
believed that there was something to
this um I don't know if he actually
believed it was it it seems like by
implication he did actually believe it
was extraterrestrial yeah well there was
physical evidence there was different
spots on the ground right real hot took
off a big old black spot so he seemed to
like not have much patience with like
the way the rest of the Air Force were
like treating it like oh it was just
like a hoax or this is nothing or
something like that because it's like
it's clearly something well they were
ordered to say it was right that's what
I'm saying he was getting kind of
disillusioned yeah
the Air Force probably was ordered to
hey this one's a hoax okay yeah
because it's just a hoax because you
know [ __ ] they're working on something
for them or the contractors are making
some kind of aircraft for them so of
course they're going to say it's a hoax
yeah that's the thing it's a vertical
landing and takeoff hypergolic rocket
fighter
the test bed for it so you can intercept
incoming nuclear bombers you know it's
what they're talking about the Germans
were trying to make [ __ ] like that in
World War II to stop our incoming
bombers just regular [ __ ] explosive
bombs well the [ __ ] Stakes were much
higher in the in the atomic age this is
uh Doctor Strange Love [ __ ] you know
and the idea of vertical Landing can
take off
something to shoot down incumbent
bombers was a good idea they didn't have
good missile guidance back then it
wasn't like you can just
launch a [ __ ] hyper you know
ultrasonic rocket and have it
successfully hit
an incoming bomber you know hundreds of
miles away yeah nah
the guides wasn't that good I mean
they had stuff to do that but a lot of
the stuff had was had a [ __ ] nuclear
warhead on it and it got went in a
couple miles and then just blew up in
the air
because it was hard it didn't have
guidance right back then
okay have you ever seen um what was it
uh Dr Strangelove remember that missile
that was tracking them down that missile
never hit him it was a mile away when it
blew up
because remember it started to diverge
yeah there's a there's a uh a proximity
fuse on there giving out a [ __ ] radio
signal when the returns when the returns
get shorter the missile knows it's
closing if it ever gets longer again it
knows it's losing track it just blows up
in a in a Inc you know and just hopes
that you knock the bomber out well
they were so inaccurate you had to put a
[ __ ] atomic bomb on the tip of it
that was the only way you were going to
you know because you were lucky to get a
mile away from that thing or you know to
get within a mile you know of some of
that stuff
so
something like this might be a good idea
something you could actually pile it you
know and get it close to
and shoot down a bomber
the rest of the Germans wanted it
back in World War II but that's that
seems like what they're talking about a
test craft
to get the landing and takeoff part
right and once you got landing and take
off of this rocket right you can then
build a fighter craft around that
but you don't spend all that money
trying to do it all at once you do it in
stages
you know well yeah you can't build the
whole thing yeah bill just like ah we
[ __ ] it yeah
they start off with something that's
just real simple and back to the drawing
board and Landing these things and
taking them off man it was never
successful dudes got killed they were
trying to do the propeller planes Jets
Rockets it's just before the age of
computers the chances that you've been
able to land on your tail nah
those dudes wiped out constantly well
that's why like all the 50s Sci-Fi
movies like always had the alien
spacecraft looking like that because I
guess that was something that they
really like wanted yeah that's what they
wanted
so you know you had the lunar lander
them legs on it
maybe they thought they could do it that
way well we'll just put legs on it
and uh you kind of sit horizontally in
it during the landing procedure and then
when you're flying forward later on
we'll rotate the seats and you can look
out the nose and fly it forward
you know but that transition period is
going to be rough
I don't think you'd be able to
successfully transition that thing maybe
you would just you're just moving the
cockpit or the like like a little ball
you know what I mean to rotate it
but this is all before computers so
you'd have to have mechanical linkages
for all your controls
you know it had computers but they
weren't any good because it was such a
[ __ ] pain before yeah yeah they had
computers but they weren't any good they
weren't I know if they figured [ __ ] out
but it's just like you know and actually
it's amazing that they figured [ __ ] out
like nowadays it seems like everything's
so easy yeah
I mean the computer on the lunar lander
was a modern day calculator would blow
it away
yeah you know I calculated from the 80s
would have blown it away that's what I
mean it's like they [ __ ] they landed
on the moon and actually with like
[ __ ] rubber bands and gum and tin
foil and pretty much and slide rules
which is crazy so this is before that
yeah several years so yeah this was
1964. this was 1964. still basically the
50s there wasn't a big difference
between the 50s and 64.
technology wasn't moving ahead that fast
really no especially not computer
technology
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
you are looking more like Anton LaVey
every day I'm just not looking at you
nothing wrong with that I don't know
James Knapp said uh your iPhone is more
powerful than the lunar lander from
Apollo that's true
which it's crazy it's crazy to think
that wow every calculator is stronger
yeah I mean everybody now just carries
around in their pocket like a [ __ ]
super computer that you know people just
even when I was a kid like you wouldn't
even have conceived of that which is
amazing no we take it for granted
because you know we've been here through
every stage of it so we were like oh
neat oh neat like when each new thing
happened but if you had just jumped
ahead
a person of the 40s 1940s and 1950s
could have never imagined that
we were from we were kids in the 80s and
I couldn't imagine a cell phone no
meeting internet and an internet and how
powerful an internet would be
like it doesn't wig me out because like
I said I started using computers when I
was you know in third grade but they
were like the really old janky like you
were you had to write your own programs
and dogs and [ __ ] like that and it's
like oh let's play wagon tray they're
all like text yeah people related you
know what I mean or like little lines
and [ __ ] yeah we we watched the the
technology we watched it all happen like
in real time yeah early early not early
internet from the 90s mid 90s internet
that was a [ __ ] trip man
it was yeah Oregon Trail yeah I remember
Oregon Trail everybody loved playing
Oregon Trail man
I agree too I wrote I wrote a Mad Libs
program when I was in fourth or fifth
grade like and I was so excited I
thought I was like a [ __ ] Tech wizard
or some [ __ ] because like because you
had to like I said you had to write your
own programming you know
um yeah Ben Farrell says uh your iPhone
is more powerful than every computer on
Earth in the 1970s yep yeah
murder Hornet says we would carry
unworkable beepers in high school in
early 90s just to look cool and I
remember too and it's funny because I
was just reading something about like a
movie that had that the other day where
it's like um you know for a long time
they had cell phones and car phones but
only super rich people could afford them
because they were really expensive and
also they were as big as a [ __ ] brick
um so some people would have like they
sold there was a there was a market for
like fake ones yeah so you could like
pretend you were like a rich drug dealer
or something somebody asked if there was
a missile in Doctor Strange stuff yeah
don't you remember
when the the B-52 that Slim Pickens was
was uh uh pilot in in Russian airspace
the Russians fired that missile at it
and that missile bit would track them
across what 30 miles probably yeah 30
miles of tracking for 30 miles and they
were trying to dodge it yeah that's
right we just watched it yeah and he
just got into a real high they went into
a steep bank and got down real low and
it the missile kind of lost lock a
little bit and started to diverge away
from it and then its Warhead went off as
it had an atomic Warhead
because it was two miles away I think
when it blew and it it still damaged the
aircraft pretty bad
because that's that's how they did it
back and I was like Missile Command
remember the damn video game Missile
Command it should blow up
you're stopping incoming bombers and
missiles with other with other uh
nuclear missiles
because they didn't have Guidance the
guidance wasn't good enough back then
the computers were weak
yeah
and it was probably a radar guided
missile anyway
I'm Ruben Pearson when I was a kid flat
screen TVs were like 10 000 bucks I
never thought I'd have one now I have
five yeah you got that in your pocket
now well and the thing yeah you can just
like watch it on your but you know even
flat screen TVs they're like so cheap
nowadays this is better than anything
out of damn uh a Star Trek next
Generation
even like Star Trek Voyager or anything
in the world yeah the little clear
plastic things they're touching on the
control yeah
yeah 70s VCRs were thousands I remember
when VCRs were really expensive like we
had a betamax
and um because you know everybody
thought that that was going to be
because it was you know it was better
technology but it just didn't win out in
the end and we didn't have a VCR until
we got a VCR I guess like in the early
to mid 80s I can't remember it was
probably like early 80s 82 something
like that
but it was really really expensive we
had to get one that was like second or
third hand I think my dad got one that
like fell off the back of a truck or
something like that because he couldn't
afford a new one blue remembers Missile
Command it's Facebook man you're
shooting down the dam killer satellites
and the [ __ ] incoming bombers and all
the damn my cousin Wesley was [ __ ]
great at it he was deaf and sit there
and he'd just totally focus on it and he
could basically play Missile Command
forever
until he got tired
it was amazing he [ __ ] he'd [ __ ]
attract whole crowds of people but he
had to have that trackball and it had to
have the big trackball not the little
trackball as long as he had that big
track ball I liked the trackball better
than that and I found that I was better
at video games like centipede and stuff
like that if it had the trackball rather
than the joystick yeah
it was more intuitive you could and it
was kind of like more sensitive I guess
well there were two
it was the same Missile Command but the
the some of the some of the like the sit
down the sit down table ones had a small
white track Ball but the stand up one
had a big heavy black trackball and once
you got it rolling it was you could keep
it rolling and it was just um
I don't know Wesley was really good at
that one because he'd spray out a whole
line of atomic explosions out in way in
layers and defend all those damp cities
from those incoming nukes
because
it was a fun game they would change
colors and
every every level was [ __ ] different
colors combinations
back then yeah got faster and faster
yeah you play it now and you're like
yeah [ __ ] this you don't worry
but you know it's just more of this okay
more of this it's just gonna get faster
but back then you weren't sure what
would happen
because you didn't know how it ended or
if it did end right it didn't end
just like Pac-Man it doesn't and I mean
to be clear there wasn't really much
else to do yeah right to be honest with
you Pac-Man doesn't end it just keeps
giving you Keys over and over again Keys
it just gets faster yeah and I think it
gets to a point where it doesn't get any
faster well obviously it stays like that
uh Wesley maxed out Pac-Man I think he
said he got fit 60 something keys he was
counting them and finally the game was
he's just like we just stopped you'd go
away
law of averages gets you you're gonna
make a mistake
and you're gonna forget it it was all
patterns yeah going through it in the
pattern
eventually you make them you make an
error in it and you can't make up for
lost grounds and a little ghosts get you
little ghosts yeah
okay let's get back to case uh okay
let's see uh I was around during Pac-Man
Fever yeah remember that song There was
a song called Pac-Man Fever I remember
them playing it at the roller rink she
was probably terrible in the early 80s
it was it's kind of like the Star Wars
song Right which Star Wars disco Star
Wars song don't you remember oh yeah I
hadn't thought about that forever that a
long time yeah honestly the only part of
the Pac-Man Fever song I remember is the
chorus part I don't remember did it have
other words or I don't remember it I
just remember them playing it at the at
the skating rink all the time I remember
there was a Pac-Man song but I don't
remember like when I don't remember who
did it I don't remember nothing about it
I remember when Donkey Kong came
[ __ ] everybody loved Donkey Kong I
like Donkey Kong wasn't my it wasn't my
favorite though and then just came out
for con home consoles and they just went
out of their way to make it as shitty as
possible
the only one that was any good I think
was coleco Vision was pretty good
I think it was clecovision yeah we
didn't have a colleague we had like the
knockoff Atari which is called Odyssey
yeah you had those too we had that I had
the Odyssey too yeah what was funny
about the Odyssey too is that it was
more expensive than the uh I think I
think it was more expensive than the
Atari and it didn't have as many games
and the graphics were a little bit
better when it came out but really you
wanted the Atari that's where all it had
well yeah all the cool kids had a Target
yeah yeah if you're a loser's like us
you haven't had Odyssey yeah
yeah so you couldn't get there was games
for it but it wasn't like Atari you know
what I mean Atari had a millions of
games it did yeah
Ben said and then Along Came missed
Pac-Man I actually liked Miss Pac-Man
better than regular Pac-Man I had one
called vex vex tracks it had it was it
was Vector scope kind of like the space
War Tempest remember White Lines
you remember that one yeah it's on
screen yeah I remember it had some
pretty good games in it had caught a
tank game I think was called armored
attack had some driving games it had a
weird win it was like you're [ __ ] A
bird just this bird flying through a
weird net I forgot that was called
solar or something or other
it was original games they were they
were pretty good well I mean when the
video game boom came along they were
just putting out any [ __ ] you know
what I mean
yeah there's a whole documentaries about
that it's fascinating actually but it's
just well it's just like any new
technology that comes along everybody's
gonna be like now it's like now in
smartphone apps it's like most of the
time
you know there's there's a bunch of good
ones but then there's like a bunch of
shitty cheap ones you know what I'm
saying eventually got the point where
[ __ ] um I just took the vectrax and
threw it away
I was in a pawn shop one time since I
got this thing called victrex he goes
yeah yeah I don't want him they didn't
want him
yeah because games are moving so fat I
bet you a vet tricks are probably worth
a lot now right well yeah because
probably because every pawn shop in
America probably told them we don't want
that one but he threw it away yeah just
threw the [ __ ] away got tired of [ __ ]
playing it and carrying that [ __ ]
around like carrying around a television
set well it wasn't that big it was about
that big
still yeah
it had a good representation of scramble
in it though remember the little
remember you're dropping the bombs and
shooting oh yeah yeah yeah you remember
Dig Dug yeah Dig Dug yeah I used to like
take Doug I just downloaded the Namco
arcade it was free on uh for Xbox 360
and then for a DOT for a dollar I got
[ __ ] Street Fighter
I'm trying to figure out yeah Tom's got
all the 80s I got all the 80s video
games like on his thing I got the Midway
Arcade
everything from Sega
Sega Genesis got them all over we got
Sonic the Hedgehog got Sonic the
Hedgehog oh I used to really like that I
think he's got all the sounds it's got
all of the [ __ ] I think it was only
20 bucks and you get everything that
Sega had
damn including Altered Beast
[ __ ] uh remember Altered Beast kinda
had the Greek Motif oh yeah yeah bigger
and bigger you get roided out eventually
and then you turn into a damn werewolf
as you find Greek ghosts
[Laughter]
yeah some crazy [ __ ] man Ben says retro
arcade game show win oh yeah we should
probably do that yeah these days I want
I got the Namco one because I also
wanted to play uh what was it ghosts and
goblins or is it called Ghouls and
ghosts I think it's called ghosts and
goblins they do jumping trying to get up
into the dam drag to this Castle
yeah throwing [ __ ] knives and [ __ ]
yeah the only one I remember like that
was Castlevania I used to play that all
yeah but I think that shit's still
around but I used to play the old one
like that was on yeah Nintendo it's got
a 1941 isn't on it cool yeah all right
yeah ghosts and goblins yeah said it was
so damn hard to finish yeah hard to
finish
you'll have to show it to me because I'm
sure I've seen it recognize it as soon
as you saw it but I don't there were so
many it's like I don't even remember and
I wasn't like super super into gaming
like we had a Nintendo and
um you know I used to play Zelda and I
used to play uh Castlevania and [ __ ]
like that then we got Sega later and
then I played um
oh it likes Metroid too I used to play
Metroid and I played Sonic the Hedgehog
but like other than that and Tetris but
that's like about all I got into like I
was doing other [ __ ] Namco arcade is
free on Xbox 360.
and you get it actual arcade you're
standing in arcade you can walk around
and you can see the game so stand again
you go up and you play them see that's
[ __ ] brilliant I like it I like that
idea then you can you can customize how
the [ __ ] cabinets look and everything
I've got to figure out how to do it I
just got it before the start of the show
though oh really you just gotta just got
it because it was free okay I want to
play Street Fighter because I'm playing
I've been playing puzzle fighter
turbo I think is what it's called where
it's like Tetris based on Street Fighter
where you got to move these colors
around and make big gems and blow them
all up and then you got the 2K you'd
like it when you see it yeah probably
and you select a character and it looks
like they're fighting but they're not
really fighting they're just threatening
each other and then they blow up they
don't really blow up they get their
asses kicked
puzzle fighter
it's like a Tetris version of Street
Fighter got the same characters in there
that's hilarious because they're like
what are two really popular games that
have absolutely nothing to do with each
other let's like mash those together
it's [ __ ] Japanese as [ __ ]
yeah yeah that sounds like that sounds
very half of them are girls and half the
characters are girls and they're you
know flashing boobs and [ __ ] up
skirting and [ __ ] like that oh that's
why you wanted it it's just everything
they're also SD super deformed so
they're short short and squat they don't
yeah they don't look realistic yeah they
look like little things little thing Ken
and Ryu and all the guys from Street
Fighter that's pretty cute yeah Chun Lee
okay you'll have to show it to me later
you'd like it it's got good music the
thing is though is that I had another
version of it is when you beat things
you unlock bonuses that had songs and
all kinds of this one's not unlocking
anything at least not at the difficulty
level I'm on I'm at maybe you got to be
on the expert difficulty level before it
starts unlocking bonus stuff
yeah yeah so oh well I don't know the
stuff for PlayStation the the
PlayStation version unlocks stuff
bonus stuff yeah bonus characters and
stuff oh well yeah all right so let's
get back to this because otherwise we'll
be here all night yeah
I know that's the thing like we get off
on these [ __ ] uh yeah Ben's talking
about man he's playing puzzle fighter
after school fun yeah yeah that's right
the South Wales puzzle fighter puzzle
fighter 2.
damn
yeah they're very noisy out no no
they're noisy it's very annoying do you
want another drink uh yeah might as well
while you're up
all right so as I mentioned earlier
um one of the big points of contention
that it seemed like they got to Lonnie's
more like pretty early about this whole
symbol that he saw on the side of this
craft or whatever because literally like
the day after he saw this stuff he was
giving a an interview with
um a radio station and this was actually
part of like I heard part of this
interview like um on a documentary I was
watching and uh they asked him about oh
did you say you know you saw a symbol
like on the side of this thing or
whatever and he said I couldn't tell you
that because they don't want me to say
anything about the markings like he said
that like and the radio station guy was
like well if we run into an area where
you don't like that they don't want you
to talk about then just say so so they'd
already got to him like
that day when they told him hey maybe
don't talk about like the symbol that
you saw so like I said even though he
did describe the symbol AS
um he described it as like a crescent
shape with a vertical Arrow pointed
upward inside the crescent and then like
a horizontal bar underneath that
um I'm not really sure if that's what he
actually saw or if that was like the
cover story they told him or whatever
I'm not really sure because Tom is
saying that
you know his son said that that wasn't
actually what the symbol looked like but
he wasn't supposed to say what the
symbol actually looked like so I'm not
really sure
um let's see
they're also
um like I said he
he's pretty clear like Lonnie Zamora as
I mentioned he doesn't say during the
interviews that he thought that it was
from outer space all he said that he he
said that it was something he hadn't
seen before and he thought that it was
maybe an experimental craft I don't
think he ever came out and said that he
thought it was from outer space and like
I said Tom said his son said the same
thing that he didn't think it was an
extraterrestrial spacecraft
um you know and he never came out and
said that
so uh there was another thing
that
um was kind of like swirling around
about this
and that some people had reported
that around where the craft was I think
that there were like Footprints where he
had seen the people but the footprints
kind of looked like hoof Prince
um are almost like hope Prince you know
what I mean like not exactly
so there were a couple of like reports
of that too and maybe that was another
thing that they had kind of like covered
up or like
sort of like swept and then pretended
that it didn't happen
um but yeah so that was another thing
that was kind of swirling around like
rumors about it
um they could look like they were on the
same side of the craft where uh Lonnie's
Morris said that he had seen the two
people and like I said I don't know how
close I don't think he got all that
close because what happened was he saw
the two people like from far away and
then when he got close to the craft
he said that he heard like a thumping
sound which he said kind of sounded like
a car door closing so you're led to
assume that the two people that he
didn't see anymore like got into the
craft and like shut the door you know
what I mean like that's he was assuming
that's what the noise was
but so he didn't get that good a look at
him but he didn't say that they looked
like aliens or nothing like that he just
said they look like people but they were
small but the thing about it was that
some people said that they did see like
Footprints but they looked more like
who's essentially so they were Satan
aliens I guess
yeah I don't know
um yeah and actually like uh Alan heinek
the guy from The Blue Book uh
investigation thing uh he actually like
alluded to the tracks also even though I
kind of feel like they wanted to kind of
hush that up that [ __ ] up uh later on as
well
um but that was something that they were
kind of looking into I don't know if
they were actually there but that was
something that some people uh brought up
now uh the thing about it too is that he
mentioned later uh the high net guy the
Blue Book guy he mentioned later that
when uh Lonnie Zamora Drew sketches of
the symbol that he saw
um he said it looked like a cattle brand
that's what it reminded him of what a
cattle brand what
the the symbol yeah yeah
so basically
um so after the story kind of started to
get some public traction
uh a lot of different theories about
what this was you know as usual started
to kind of like come to the fore
IGN now one astronomer from Harvard uh
he's basically saying and this was the
attack that skeptical Inquirer took as
well because they did like a long
article about this which is online if
you want to read it
they were of the opinion that Lonnie
Zamora had actually been the target of a
hoax
by uh students from the uh the close by
like the um
what is it called like New Mexico Tech
or whatever it was yeah New Mexico Tech
like the college that was nearby
apparently I don't know if this is true
or not but I did like read on a couple
of sources that Lonnie Zamora used to
work on that campus and some of the
students didn't like him
and so some people have posited that uh
they decided they were going to pull a
prank on him although I was like well
how would they know that he was going to
be in that particular location that day
I'm not really sure like how that worked
but you know what I mean thank you Bryce
just tuned in fascinated with UFOs
though I'm usually skeptical great show
thank you very much thank you very much
that's really really awesome of you
and yeah so uh but there was kind of
like a couple of
um
letters or emails that were exchanged
between people that worked at the school
like later on
that suggested that it might have been
like a hoax there was
um the president of New Mexico Tech at
the time whose name was Sterling Colgate
he actually said
that
um he thought that students had done it
and that the craft was actually a candle
in a balloon that's what he said now it
is noted though that one of the first
things that samura said he at first he
did say that it kind of looked like a
balloon but the thing about it was that
the day was really really windy and the
way that he described it moving didn't
really seem like the way that a balloon
would move like on a really really windy
day just saying
um you also have another skeptic named
Stuart Campbell who said that what
Lonnie Zamora saw was probably a mirage
from the star canopus
yeah
um which yeah that seems a little out
there
also you got a couple people saying that
he saw ball lightning
which
you know I don't know ball lightning is
weird but I don't know he seems to have
seen it from pretty close and he seemed
to have given a good description of it
and like I said I don't think that it's
I don't necessarily think it's
extraterrestrial I think that his
assessment was correct I think that he
saw like an experimental craft that was
military or scientific or something like
that and they didn't want him to see it
so they told him to shut the [ __ ] up
about it basically I think that's what
happened
um also like the same person that said
that maybe it was ball lightning then he
came out later and said oh well maybe
Lonnie Zamora like pulled this hoax
himself
in order to attract tourism to the area
which I'm like well if that was what he
wanted to do it didn't [ __ ] work
because everybody knows about Roswell
but nobody talks about going to Socorro
for UFO tourism I don't think unless
they're like really hardcore you know
ridiculous yeah I was like that seems
like a stretch you know what I mean it
seems like I'm not saying it's
impossible people do weird [ __ ] all the
time but it wasn't just him that saw it
that's what I mean it does there was
evidence behind he didn't go out there
and Scorch the damn ground and make damn
near glass out of their [ __ ] that's
when I was a rocket landing sound Zone
it's like it's I mean whether if it was
a hoax I don't think it was him that was
perpetrated it was somebody else doing
it I don't think it was a hoax
perpetrated by somebody else because
like I said if it was a hoax perpetrated
I mean I could see if it was a hoax you
know just in general you know and
whoever happened to see it you know gold
but I don't think it was a hoax
perpetrated against him specifically
because like I said how would you know
that he was going to be there he was
only on that stretch of road because he
was chasing a speeder that particular
day New Mexico is a great place for
testing experimental aircraft
and test vehicles
that particular layout
something kind of like a lunar lander
was real dangerous dudes got killed
trying to land those things they were
doing it manually you know like he would
try to fly a helicopter
before computers it was real easy for it
to tip over
on Landing or takeoff and then to try to
fly in an area but they were messing
with those things this is confirmed
messing with those things trying to
practice
to get an idea of what it was going to
be like to land on the Moon
it stands to reason that that's real
closely linked up with a lot of vertical
landing and takeoff fighter Concepts
that went back all the way back to the
40s with the Germans
so you know your big contractors are
going to be working on that kind of
stuff
now
we know that that's a [ __ ] unstable
[ __ ] design
especially with the technology they had
back then now you can do what musk is
doing land it down
rocket on a [ __ ] barge out at Sea on
at Rough Seas they could only dream of
[ __ ] like that you got to have really
good computers to do that
this was some contractor took this test
vehicle out somewhere and they they lost
control over it and it ended up leaving
the damn test facility
you know they were [ __ ] difficult to
fly
so they ended up being spotted by
civilians that's that's the most
plausible thing
yeah I think like
um probably I think the most plausible
is that because I've heard that it was
actually like an experimental lunar
lander it could be
um so that's what I'm saying yeah and
yeah they could have been testing it and
they [ __ ] up and it's like they were
somewhere they weren't supposed to be
well it's easy for that [ __ ] to [ __ ]
right get out of hand because the danger
is it flipping over as soon as it gets
Beyond a certain
axis like that you're [ __ ] it's gonna
you know
there's no there's no
lifting surfaces on it is pure thrust so
there's no Wing there's no rotor
and
it's not being held from above it's
being pushed up from the bottom
it's like riding a pogo stick you know
it'd be really easy for something like
that to
get get out from underneath you and then
you're [ __ ] 10 miles away from where
you should be and you've left the range
and then you've got to land and try to
get out for a second and get yourself
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
there might have been something wrong
with it
yeah that's why you know maybe that's
why he saw the two dudes because like I
said he didn't say that the dudes like
looked weird he just said they looked
short yeah and they saw somebody coming
we got to get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
it's like we can't see this they're not
supposed to see this yeah this is
experimental yeah all right I gotta run
to the bathroom so that's most likely
what I think it was I kind of think
that's probably what it was yeah and it
would be easy for something like that to
get out like to get out of hand and you
[ __ ] end up 10 20 miles away doing
little hops
and each little hop you're going deeper
outside the range trying to figure out
how this thing [ __ ] how to fly this
thing
now
you would think
about how much fuel could something like
that carry
the 160 the me163 comet really didn't
carry that much fuel
and you were able to launch it from the
ground and be way up
[ __ ] at high altitude inside a bomber
stream just in a few minutes
you only had a few minutes
of flight time up there
and then you eject you cut the you cut
the power to the engines some of them
actually the engines would [ __ ] you
can release it and they fall out the
back and go to the go to the go to the
ground on a parachute on some designs
but then you just flew it around as a as
a glider
but it was going
hundreds of miles an hour so it could
Coast at a high speed for a long time
faster than a propeller play
I'm trying to think of how fast that
thing was I think they were close to 600
miles an hour if I remember correctly
and it was just kind of a boomerang
shaped
little airplane small
so uh yeah it's gone 600 miles an hour
and it's not really slowing down that
quickly and you could cut loops with it
and pick up speed during Dives
so but you know something like this like
a Lander type configuration
they weren't flying high they said they
said it was what 30 feet over the ground
not even and I said it was more like 10
to 15 feet because he said there was
like a dynamite shock and he said it was
like only like three feet over the roof
so they're not burning fuel to gain
altitude they're staying low to the
ground
so yeah I wouldn't surprise me if that
they could go 30 miles Maybe
especially if it was hopping you know
they were having problems with it and
they were only a few feet off the ground
they'd landed they were probably afraid
of it you know you get up high I would
be easier to [ __ ] up and kill yourself
yeah
and uh you hypergolic Rockets
it's just you're just mixing two
chemicals
two fluids together and they explode
without any
ignition system they you know no
ignition source so you don't need a
spark plug or any Jetta Flame or
anything you just mix those two things
together boom
explode one of them is uh pure carbon uh
pure hydrogen peroxide I forgot what the
other one was I think it might have been
nitric acid or some [ __ ] like that
they were very caustic if you got any of
that on you it reduced you to pink foam
all right it just ate right through you
both like fun yeah
one of them was extremely base and the
other one was extremely acid and when
they [ __ ]
met each other they just exploded in
[ __ ] Flame
but it was had a real good power to
weight ratio
so if you're piloting something like
this the last thing you'd ever wanted to
do is to crash it
because if you rupture those fuel tanks
that would be bad
you rupture those fuel tanks and the
thing will just blow up like a bomb yeah
okay and uh usually it consumes one fuel
faster than the other
so you end up with just some hydrogen
peroxide left which that's what happened
in the comet a lot and on Landing
if they landed hard because it didn't
have landing gear on it just had a skid
and they'd landed out in a field
because it was a glider basically it was
a rocket powered glider once the [ __ ]
fuel was burned up well they'd landed on
the skid and usually like something like
a wingtip would touch down on the ground
and it's tumble and they'd ruptured fuel
tanks and the guide get covered and
hydrogen peroxide
pure hydrogen peroxide
and they had them they had them in
rubber suits like a space suit with a
big square glass plate on them on the on
the face but the rubber suit got ripped
up and all that [ __ ] twisted aluminum
by the time the ground crew usually got
to them they were nothing but just a
rubber suit filled with a skeleton and
pink foam that's Rudy yeah is he hates a
half to like [ __ ] yeah they're like
well we'll just pick it up in the bag
and just put it in the grave yeah yeah
just eat you up he's so gross yeah it's
like the Germans have a ball smoothie
the Germans had [ __ ] balls
you guys can search look for as the
me163 comet with a k
[ __ ] rocket fighter and Rocket
interceptor it's like a football look
like a damn football like an American
football with [ __ ] sweat back Wings
on it and a little [ __ ] tail just
didn't have a it just had a stabilizer
it didn't have any lifting like the
aileron type things on tail just just
look like a little fat shark
it was a little fat shark so it looked
like it wasn't very big
and uh you know it was little
little fat shark with a man in it
you were [ __ ] crazy if you got that
thing man
I'm telling you now every time now every
time until I die like if I go to
7-Eleven and get like a cherry Slurpee
I'm gonna think of that story the pink
foam
skeleton and the skeleton I think I
could be drinking a little German man
it was testing some experiments yeah
it was a whole series of those we were
making something like that it's called
The Flying Ram it was just like a dam
look like a boomerang you laid down in
it
and it had a little armored glass window
and it had a sharp Leading Edge on the
wing and it had a couple little
stabilizers and they were going to be it
was a gyrojet rocket which they never
really figured out how to do it was like
it was kind of like a the German
hypergolic rocket but I think they were
there was rotojet is what they called it
there was some kind of compressor blades
in it
probably to get the feed fuel faster so
you can get more power
but evidently they didn't work too they
kept blowing up so then they put jet
engines in it and the idea was just to
ram a bomber and survive it because it
was kind of like a because they didn't
have guided missiles
I didn't I don't even think it carried
weapons it just had a an armored Leading
Edge and it was real narrow and you laid
down in it and you flew it right through
the tail of a bomber right through the
fuselage and cut right through it
then you could do it multiple times
but guided missiles got rid of all that
[ __ ]
50s 50s and 60s stuff
Daniel Rowling said did this guy get a
good look at the faces of the aliens I
don't think so I think because he saw
the figures like far away like they were
standing around the thing but by the
time he got close to it it seemed like
they had got back into it and taken off
again but like I said he didn't seem to
think that they looked weird just small
his son told us that he didn't think
that his dad didn't think they were
aliens
because I knew his son his son was my
squad leader so yeah that's what Danny
Rowling asked it's like Tom what did
this guy's son tell you about his father
he was just a cop man that he was real
patriotic and that he didn't think it
was an he didn't think it was an alien
craft he thought it was a test craft but
they made him say things to lead the
public
it is just like thinking he was crazy
yeah there was a misinformation campaign
because it was some [ __ ] that I didn't
want anybody to know about what I'm
doing they want you to ask him questions
about it so they just wanted to Cloud it
up with a bunch of stuff
to get the public to it put the public
in a tailspin to not believe it
basically well like I said the poor guy
I don't think his life was ruined
necessarily but he did get made fun of a
lot decomposite it kind of like bummed
him out you know what I mean they
compensated him
they paid him for his time I mean they
better according to his head now I don't
know how much they paid him but he
didn't say well the thing about it it's
like if I saw a UFO I don't think I'd
tell anybody [ __ ] he was he was
um I know how that goes
um
Zamora's dad who's the the cop they're
talking about Lonnie Zamora and I
believe my I believe my squad Leader's
name I believe his first name was Lonnie
also which would have made him the Third
um he said that his dad was real
patriotic okay and that he did his duty
he
if they told him to do this he would
have done it
yeah National Defense stuff well and
that's and people were kind of more like
that back then like if if they said well
you have to do this and that everybody
be like well yes sir nowadays it'd be
like no we're not doing that he never
says it's alien even in his no he
doesn't he doesn't say it he never I
know that as far as I'm aware like I
said I didn't really read like the whole
transcript but as far as I know he never
said that he thought that it was nuts he
told my squad leader that he thought it
was a test aircraft a test craft
that's what I believe it was yeah I mean
he was weirded out at first because it's
like he didn't know what it was like it
was weird looking they're not describing
alien technology it launches it gives a
lot of smoke behind it a booming [ __ ]
sound
that's a [ __ ] rocket
Rockets because most of the time I kind
of feel like most of the time when
people report like UFO UFOs it's usually
like oh my God it was so quiet and it
was like really really weird but this
one like very uh specifically was not
quiet he said it hurt he heard a roaring
noise which that describes the me-163
comet the hypergolic rocket
perfectly they just said it was just
amazingly loud and it's not big you know
so just screaming [ __ ] loud
the tuck and temperature of that
combustion is [ __ ] high and it's
almost damn near external combustion the
engine in the thing was only about that
big it was just a it was just a block of
cast iron with a [ __ ] cone in it two
[ __ ] holes where there were valves
and the two two things could just a
combustion chamber and then the little
the little nozzle wasn't very big you
know what I mean that that drove that
aircraft and it was like damn near
breaking the sound barrier almost
you know probably could break the sound
barrier in a dive it's just that that's
not how they were using it in a power
dive you could probably easily break
sound barrier in a comet I don't think
that I don't think it would hold
together
because breaking the sound barrier does
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] up things to
aerodynamics you got to be shaped just
right if not it starts to wobble and
[ __ ] tumble
you know which it probably would have
done that but you would have broke the
sound barrier
yeah yeah
they say the [ __ ] P-38 Lightning was
breaking the sound barrier in a dive and
that was a propeller plane
and you a lot of times it wouldn't come
out of a [ __ ] dive and because you'd
lose control over you hit the Earth
[Laughter]
they'd solved that though they put
special flaps on it so it would write
itself in that dive compressibility is
what it's called
but some people reported a sonic boom of
a P-38 in a dive
hard to believe but maybe maybe it's
certain
maybe a certain
um
altitudes maybe low altitude Maybe
because it happens that's not impossible
I mean you know
be surprised at that airframe would hold
together but that's what I'm saying it's
close it seems unlikely but
you know weirder things have happened I
guess
um so here's something kind of
interesting while I was looking into the
Zamora case
there was another reported UFO case that
happened on the exact same day
um that I kind of wanted to like bring
up because I actually never heard of
this before and I don't know if you have
either
so it happened the same day but it was
like across the country
so even though the one in Socorro New
Mexico is considered like one of the
best documented and one of the most
credible sightings and like I said
nobody's saying that it's necessarily
alien technology they're just saying
that you know obviously something was
there and a lot of people saw it and
there's a lot of corroborating evidence
and stuff like that
however this other case that happened
it's happened in um New York actually in
Newark Valley which is that Upstate New
York I'm not entirely sure but there was
this guy named Gary Wilcox they call
this the fertilizer case for reasons
which will become clear as we go along
but this happened on the exact same day
April 24th
1964. and it's weird because I don't
think I mean because the Lonnie Zamora
citing it happened like late in the day
and I don't think that the story went
National
in time for this guy to have read about
it and said oh I'm gonna do the same
[ __ ] but then some of the stuff that he
said some of the stuff he says batshit
crazy but some of the stuff he said too
was like similar
to what uh what Lonnie's Morris said
which I thought was like really really
weird
because I don't think there's any way
that he could have like read about this
Amore case and like beforehand because
it happened the same day
so basically this Gary Wilcox guy
he said that he saw
um the same kind of thing like as an
egg-shaped craft he didn't say that he
saw like a symbol on the side or
anything he didn't remember that
but he did see like an egg-shaped craft
similar kind of size and color and
everything
and he said that he saw it Landing
and that shortly afterward like two
little dudes like they were about four
feet tall like approached him
and he said I had to include this
because it's like kind of funny
he said that each of them had a little
they were carrying like a tray like it
was like a square tray like in their
hands like that
and then he said like on the tray were
all of these like soil samples and like
roots and leaves and [ __ ]
he said they had white metallic suits on
like flight suits which is the same
thing that Lonnie's more reported yeah
I'm smelling a rat I'm just saying this
is [ __ ] good
now then he said one of the dudes one of
the little dudes he didn't say they look
like aliens or nothing he just said they
looked like little like Shore people
pretty much
he said that one of the dudes came up to
him and said don't be alarmed we've
spoken to people before
but I was like okay
um and then he said I could understand
what they were saying but I couldn't
tell if they were speaking English or
not and he said that their voices
sounded like really really weird like no
voices that he could ever describe
um and then he said that they started
asking him all these questions because
he was a farmer so they started like
asking him all these questions about
like farming and stuff like what like
what is it that you're doing right now
like what is a tractor like what what is
manure like all this other kind of stuff
and said that they were really
interested in like organic substances
yeah he said he stood there talking to
them for like two hours yeah and they
were asking him like all these really
but it's mostly about farming and like
how that was all going
um
and they said and yeah and they and he
said that they had like they were really
interested in fertilizer yeah so or [ __ ]
so yeah maybe thank you Bryce banned
from doing super chats for ages this is
to make up for that oh thank you I
wonder why you were banned from doing
Super Chat we did it we didn't do that
we didn't do it we didn't do it I can't
do anything from here but yeah so uh so
suddenly he talks to them for two hours
about various farming techniques or
whatever and then uh the two guys were
like yeah I gotta go you know what I
mean
um so he was like Hey like do you want a
bag of fertilizer to take with you like
do you want to study it or something
like that and they were like no no we
don't have time to like hang around for
that [ __ ] so then they get back in
the egg craft and it goes up in the and
he described it like I said the same way
as Lonnie Zamora described it like the
same kind of roaring motor noise
um he said it sounded like an idling car
engine kind of but it's like I said he
said it looked like an egg and then it
was like kind of gliding or like
hovering a little and then like took off
in the distance like really fast
now he said that he went back and like
left a bag of fertilizer like kind of by
the tree like where the craft was but
then like when he went back there later
on the fertilizer was gone like they
came back and took it and like took it
back to their planet or whatever
now he actually reported this
to the NYPD like or I guess the New York
police or wherever he was like the
police department where he lived
and he had like a bunch of UFO
researchers and [ __ ] like that like come
and newspaper people like come and talk
to him
um and he seemed like super serious
about it now he never did try to like
make money off it or nothing like that
um and he's like yeah if it happened
again I would still like report it to
you guys but he didn't like I said he
didn't really seem to try to become
famous about it or anything but I just
thought it was really weird because it
happened the exact same day as the
Lonnie Zamora thing and it still had the
egg-shaped craft and like the noise and
all this stuff yeah well no he yeah he
reported it okay say the police okay so
I just thought that was really really
weird and like saying oh the little
people in the white suits and everything
I said that sounds exactly and he was
just a farmer yeah he was just a farmer
okay but I just thought that was like
super super strange not really it's not
really strange at all
what it is how about you want to bet
somebody from the FBI came forward and
says look we want you to tell this story
we're going to give you ten thousand
dollars
maybe so oh yeah that's just a throw up
a lot more chaff maybe it wanted to to
uh to discredit the other story that
they knew was coming because yeah
because this one is like way silly way
silly like with him talking to the guys
about like manure or whatnot so and then
like I don't want to lie and it's well
here's the 10 000 and you're helping
you're you're helping your government oh
okay this is your purpose you know this
is your patriotic Duty you know and
you're going to get paid uh we have to
keep you know we have to discredit this
other thing over here that happened
you know that's that's probably what
that was it might have been but that was
that was pretty quick acting because
like I said it did happen like on the
same okay guys that know how to do that
I guess so and it was like across the
country too
so it's like I thought that was like
super funny I don't know just like that
whole
I'm just imagining the whole kind of
like situation where like two little
alien dudes feel like coming down like
asking about hey you want a bag of
fertilizer you can have a bag of
fertilizer no that's okay we don't have
time for that right now
I don't think but um other than the most
they got feed stores around here that
you could probably get fertilizer there
but I just thought that was like super
funny but yeah that probably is now that
I think about it
because I mean Lonnie Zamora like he saw
the stuff like I said on April 24th and
it was like the evening it was like 6
p.m like somewhere around there 5 45 6
p.m
and
so what
okay yeah Pookie's talking
she's like yelling about something and
tearing up this thing over there
but I didn't like like I said they had
to have worked fast because I mean by
the time he reported it like the
military didn't really get there until
the next day but like if he did kind of
report it to the authorities like maybe
and like I said White Sands is right
there so maybe they kind of
figured it out they said hey send
somebody out like somewhere it doesn't
matter where and make up like a weird
story that's like kind of similar to
that
possible I guess because like I said
interesting the way
during the interviews like Zamora did
say you know I thought it was an
experimental aircraft and they're kind
of trying to steer him away from that I
don't think they ever explicitly came
out and said hey we want you to say it's
aliens but they did seem to be kind of
trying to discredit him saying that it
was an experimental aircraft which would
make sense if it was something that they
didn't want getting out so it's just
kind of like well we'll just make it as
ridiculous as possible and like I said
his story wasn't really that ridiculous
but the one with the fertilizer people
that's pretty ridiculous I just thought
that was funny and I'd never heard of
that story before and it's like when I
was researching this I was like the
fertilizer case Gary Wolf is like I
never heard of that so I looked into it
and I'm like okay
[Laughter]
and how far away was that it was across
the country it was in New York like
whereas the Lonnie's more case was New
Mexico so it was like two thousands of
miles away it could be sheer luck but
that sounds like something that they the
FBI would know if it traveled all this
way that way that way if they got any
more resistance they could pull that out
you know what I mean oh you believe that
you know what I mean this is a UFO
because look way over here
this guy saw the same thing you know
they were talked about farming and
everything little people with tray is
full of roots and soil things so you're
trying to make the case look as
ridiculous as possible and to kick up a
bunch of UFO freaks to talk about it
which this which
[ __ ] uh it it puts the case in into
disrepute you know what I mean [ __ ]
makes it seem ridiculous because another
thing he said too is like where the
craft landed the guy that had the farm
yeah he said that where the craft landed
same as you know the New Mexico case
that um that the ground where it uh had
parked was like radioactive and nothing
would grow on it for like a long time
after was there a burn spot though a
little bit of a burn spot yeah it was
like kind of a circular patch where it
was like burned and like radioactive
yeah
that's uh apparently yeah well you know
in the 60s a lot of these people came
out of the 50s of course you know people
at his age and their concept of of any
kind of spacecraft landed on its tail it
was a rocket some kind of nuclear rocket
because that's what sci-fi movies had if
you notice Sci-Fi movies all the Rockets
land on their tails
they were trying to do that but they
couldn't do that
you can do it now yeah I couldn't do
that back then no like I said that's why
it was very sci-fi eBay yeah
look at that it's alien technology
James Knapp said could be they were
doing tests on the same day on both
sides of the country and the test pilots
were found by the farmer and they acted
dumb to get the farmer to go away I
don't know maybe that would be like
super funny unlikely that's even funnier
than if they were aliens yeah it's like
let's pretend to be aliens come on this
will be like [ __ ] that sounds like
some [ __ ]
New York New York that entire state is
not a good place to test secret aircraft
that's why they do it out in the desert
yeah
but you know
government or the government contractors
have a lot of land out there and it's
just barren
[ __ ] well yeah that's why I think
it's emblematic what why like so many
UFO sightings happen like in desert
locations it's always because that's
where they're testing [ __ ] yeah I don't
think it's because that's why it was
like aliens come here because to check
out that we're testing [ __ ] I think that
you're seeing [ __ ] that they're testing
I think most of the time they got test
ranges out there for aircraft in the air
where an aircraft can [ __ ] hit Mach
3.
and go in a straight line that would be
damn near the range is bigger than a
European country you know
which it's a trip but you know the
[ __ ] those desert states are big
they're big
yeah I've uh
I've been to New Mexico actually it's
beautiful out there desert's not really
my thing
but I mean the landscape out there is
amazing yeah just pretty it is very
pretty I went to
um I was in Santa Fe like Santa Fe was
like really really pretty so like really
the land around there is really pretty
do you know I've been to Colorado too
but
I was kind of blessed geographically
because it had
such a a wide variety of places of
terrain and those deserts came
they came in handy man for nuclear
testing and tested aircraft and
everything we were setting off atomic
bombs out there then they ended up
moving them to like the Bikini Atoll
they were did a bunch of them out there
but they set off atomic bombs right
there on the [ __ ] surface of the
desert yes well like I said there's
nobody around you know what I mean like
for miles and miles yeah well [ __ ] like
I said even nowadays as many people live
in the U.S you can drive through Texas
Arizona [ __ ] like that you can drive
like on [ __ ] highways and there's
like nothing yeah there's nothing out
there
you know what I mean it's just like
[ __ ] flat land as far as you can see
they had that Davy Crockett
Atomic recoilers rifle is like something
about a damn Fallout
videos of them firing that thing off out
of the desert people watching it and
then um
they did tests like they set off an
atomic bomb and then have guys army guys
run into [ __ ] Ground Zero
after the detonation to prove that
radiation wasn't a problem
yeah how'd that work out
a lot of those dudes died yeah I was
gonna say in their 60s not dangerous oh
no
it took a long time to get to them
though you know really what it was is my
understanding is that they knew that
there was a danger they didn't know how
dangerous it was so they were gonna
[ __ ] find out they're gonna run those
dudes in there and see how long they
lived
yeah they did that kind of [ __ ] all the
time I think most of them were just
cheap back then yeah well
life expectancy in in World War II
wasn't very [ __ ] high for a soldier
you know
especially if you were on the losing
side the Germans pretty much just
annihilated anybody who was fighting in
a German Army the chances of you coming
home alive are [ __ ] Slim
and a lot of [ __ ] Russians died
millions of them
yeah so this whole idea of [ __ ] well
yeah uh radiation might you might not
live until your 60s and they're like oh
[ __ ] that's a whole lifespan
you know yeah it's like that's years
away who cares yeah they were like oh 60
that's when you're supposed to die
I kind of thought that way yeah you know
it's like once you get to our age and
you're like oh [ __ ] man it's like it's
yeah I'm only 10 years old you know
people lived to old age but not as many
right back then yeah it wasn't like the
expectation I think most people nowadays
like expect that they're gonna live
about to be like a hundred Yeah well
yeah maybe not 100 but are gonna live
like longer than like they don't think
they're gonna drop dead at [ __ ] 55 or
so lucky to make it to 70 or 80. 75 but
I mean [ __ ] I mean like I said we know
well actually [ __ ] our friend will
uh we saw him on Friday and he just
turned 60. just turned six you would
never ever no looking at him he was 60
years old ever
no he's on a juice though he's helping
him he's like oh man I feel good I had
totally forgotten that he I knew he was
older than me but I didn't really think
about it and then like Friday it was his
birthday and I was like oh [ __ ] that's
right you turned 60s he's looking
younger
yeah that's what I mean he looks good
you would never know he's looking
younger he was 60 years old testosterone
man works
it's just funny that yeah
a 60 year old back well [ __ ] man even
six years of old man even people will
even you watch movies from the 50s or
something like that even people in there
that were like 35 looked old as [ __ ] yep
I don't know what it was but
not everybody like not everybody looked
old but a lot of people did
will looks will looks like he's in his
40s late 40s
right
but [ __ ] I was like I was watching like
I said I was watching one of those MST
3K shorts and there was a girl in there
well a woman in there that was supposed
to be a college student but she was like
obviously much older than college and
I'm sitting there going oh my God that
woman looks like she's like 50 years old
and they're trying to pass her off as a
college student so I got curious to see
how old she really was like the actress
and then she was 38 and I was like so I
was like oh that's a rough 38 though I I
would have thought that she was at least
50 like looking at her I just thought I
mean it was so obvious that she was like
older and they were trying to pass her
off as like a college student like the
other actors that they had in there that
was also playing a college student was
supposed to be the same age looked more
like a college student like she looked
like she could conceivably be in her 20s
but this other woman was clearly much
much older but I thought she was at
least 10 to 15 years older than she
actually was so I don't know why they
thought they could
pull the wool over anybody's eyes but
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like the blob they wanted us to believe
that Steve McQueen was a [ __ ] high
school student in that movie when he
looked like he was about 40 years old
he was at 40 at the time and he looked
like he was 40. not in a bad way it's
just like they looked older
you know and I saw a video the other day
that was explaining like some uh reasons
for maybe why that was but not
necessarily just because I mean one of
the factors was that maybe like the
health wasn't as good or
you know stuff like that but you know
there were other reasons as well having
to do with like you know how they
dressed and all this other kind of stuff
uh Hugo said I think people looked older
back then because life was harder also
they got married and had kids way
younger yeah I kind of feel like that
might have been a factor as well because
you were just kind of expected to sort
of like
you know start a family either right out
of high school or right out of college
so either 18 or 22 and then start
pumping kids out and you know having
kids ages you usually not always but a
lot of times it does you know what I
mean which is maybe one reason why I
don't look old as [ __ ] because I never
had any
that might be why I just have I just
have a fur babies and they're like and
they're less they're less stressful yeah
stress to get you and [ __ ] career
yeah that too
but yeah I wanted to kind of bring up
too like other than the um the Gary
Wilcox uh the fertilizer the fertilizer
aliens apparently
when I was looking at this case too they
said that there were a lot of other UFO
sightings around this same time period
uh you know and kind of in the same
general area not necessarily New Mexico
but like out in the desert at least like
10th of April which was like two weeks
beforehand
um they got uh I guess like
NORAD in uh I guess that's Merced Merced
California they picked up
um between half a dozen and a dozen
anomalous objects like up in the sky
um and they got them on radar and
everything like that they said they were
flying between sixty thousand and ninety
thousand feet they actually like sent
some Jets out to check it out but didn't
see anything but they did like pick them
up on radar
and then
um about a week after that like I think
at April 17th
um there were like the the radar picked
up like two weird objects at Fallon Air
Base in Nevada and they were kind of
flying like one on top of the other like
sack formation and uh people saw them
for about an hour and then they
disappeared
two days after the Zamora incident in
Las Vegas
um some people saw like 12 very bright
silver objects moving through the sky
toward the South
um and they moved one way like for 30
seconds and then changed course all at
the same time and then started going
back North again like they turned around
and then on the 28th of April which was
four days after the Zamora incident
while also in New Mexico this was in
Albuquerque there were a couple of kids
who reported seeing an egg-shaped object
like hovering in the sky over their
Elementary School
um and one of them said that the object
kind of bounced up and down in the sky
and then like took off
uh and also that same little girl uh
actually apparently allegedly reportedly
uh went and had to have medical
attention for burns on her face
um so that so there were kind of like
weird things going on but like I said I
kind of feel like
that area of the desert there's so many
testing ranges there's so many military
bases there's so many everything that's
kind of why there's so much
so many UFO sightings out there I kind
of feel like most of it's because of
that you know yeah
so what did they do so in uh Socorro New
Mexico
um a couple years after the incident I
guess because it was really famous at
the time
so the guy who was the president of the
Chamber of Commerce and Socorro at the
time he said he wanted to do like he
wanted to pull a Roswell which I don't
even think like the Roswell [ __ ] had
been like really developed to the extent
that it is today like in this year so
maybe this was a little bit ahead of its
time I'm not really sure but he was like
yeah we're gonna do it like a tourist
site like Sakura so ever all the UFO
ologists will come here and like we'll
have [ __ ] gift shops and [ __ ] like
that so they're gonna um they actually
did a little bit like they built like
some stone walkways they built like
little benches and stuff like where the
landing site was and whatnot although
they [ __ ] it up I think they put like
the the site where the all the tourists
were supposed to come
was uh like a quarter mile away from
where the actual Landing site was so
they kind of messed that up and um it
never really turned into like a tourist
site like they were hoping
um and then basically what they've done
now is much like they did in uh in
Roswell they actually had a couple of
artists in 2012 that did this like big
mural like um you know kind of
commemorating it or whatever and uh
apparently lot poor Lonnie Zamora uh
according to Wikipedia said he became so
tired of the subject that he eventually
avoided both ufologists and the Air
Force and uh took a job managing a gas
station okay yeah because he was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] forever which like I said
I get it like that's your one claim to
fame in life it's like you can't do
anything without everybody and their
mother like asking you about that [ __ ]
and it probably gets really old so you
know what I'm saying so well you know
it's just kind of like the same thing
it's like I'm sure that like the same
thing over and over again right just
listen to my damn videotape yeah it's
like read my book just go away you know
what I mean it's like I'm tired of like
repeating myself all the time
um yeah so like I said he did he died on
uh in 2009. he had a heart attack uh he
was 76 years old so yeah he got real
sick of that alien [ __ ] at the end so
he's probably like like I said I kind of
feel like if I saw a UFO
I do not even if I thought it was alien
technology I'm pretty sure I would not
report that
I just that can only end in tears to be
honest with you yeah I saw it saw that
Poltergeist we didn't say anything about
it at the time
other than people people I mean would
you like if you saw a UFO and like and
you really legitimately thought that it
was a UFO and maybe not like an
experimental aircraft or whatever you
would think I wouldn't report that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you would think a UFO would be
more credible that more believable than
something let's say like Poltergeist
phenomenon or out of body experiences
and stuff you know I mean you think oh
yeah alien creatures the big universe
it's hard to believe that people
wouldn't believe that but in this
particular case that they're just not
describing a UFO they're not describing
an alien craft
the the intelligence agencies are making
it sound like a hokey alien craft
sighting they're trying to discredit it
because they don't want people talking
about it they want they want they want
UFO freaks to talk about it
basically
yeah because they know that everybody
will be like ah you know everybody just
thinks they're yeah
but like I said I kind of feel like yeah
I mean
it's a UFO in the sense that yeah he
didn't know what it was so it was
identified but like I said even he
didn't think it was alien spacecraft and
I don't really think it's aliens but it
was weird for sure like it was it scared
him whatever it was like he wasn't it
was looked like nothing he was used to
so it freaked him out but I don't think
he thought it was alien technology or
anything his son said
that his dad
believed it was a test craft yeah he
didn't think it was an alien even when
it happened he reported it
because he thought that's what you're
supposed to do
little did he know well like I said it
was 1964. yeah he reported it to his
Department right you know and then it
got out of hand
well the thing is it's like what yeah I
mean he didn't really mean to because
like I said he was a cop so it was kind
of like his job he saw something and
he's like oh [ __ ] he thought it was a
plane crash or some [ __ ] like that I'm
gonna go check that out so he's like
checking into the radio and then he's
reporting back so yeah it kind of got
out of yeah
it turned out it was a research craft
well
[ __ ] like it's a secret project the
government's got to do something they
got to come in here and confuse the
confuse the case and Cloud the issues
and put a misinformation campaign out
there and that's what they did
they did the desolate one said Tom if
you've seen a UFO would you bolt or go
investigate oh man go investigate yeah
he definitely would well sometimes we'll
be driving home from the club at night
and he'll be like
I really wish I could see a UFO yeah
yeah
I wonder about it all the time yeah see
I want to see one of those gigantic
[ __ ] triangles he wants to see one of
the big blacks like something out of
them
the Phoenix light he used to like to lay
in the bed and like look out at our old
house and like look out the sliding
glass yeah Windows like in the backyard
so he could look up in this guy and see
if there was aliens right he kept
waiting yeah he's still on the scene
while you go you got a wild cell you can
still see it you could still see one
I keep hoping that you'll see one that
whole Phoenix Lights thing was [ __ ]
amazing too everybody who saw it [ __ ]
said that no that was an alien craft
yeah I'm not talking about the flares
that is flares that they keep showing
there's only one video of the actual
craft and it's real grainy and fuzzy and
it doesn't look good on camera you'll
see like five lights in a V from a
distance to somebody with an
old-fashioned VHS
quarters trying to zoom in on it
and it doesn't really show
it doesn't show any context but people
say that that's it but there's nothing
in the video showing where the ground is
and so it's hard to say you can't really
see like yeah
um but
too many people called 9-1-1
and it went across the state
so several cities wasn't just Phoenix
so that means it wasn't planes flying in
formation they couldn't have covered
that much distance in that amount of
time
they were speeding up and slowing down
they'd speed up in between cities to
slow down when they'd be over a city so
it was some kind of parade they were
they were meant to be seen and it was
more than one of them it wasn't just one
craft it was several of them
and they were triangles and they're just
or just a little light a little little
uh light a little ball of light
it was the aliens annual let's [ __ ] with
the earthlings parade
I hope they have that that would be so
funny
they're like periodically let's just go
down there and [ __ ] with them come on
yeah that would be so funny because
that's what I would do if I was an alien
I don't think it's a ship okay I don't
think they're ships people these are
spaceships
I don't think so I think it's more kind
of like the monolith out of 2001.
um they didn't have I could imagine what
was happening in there and they didn't
have
the vocabulary even up until recently
but now I can explain what I think it is
it's a craft
that could
that could travel in between it's
Interstellar craft
it has
the souls
of millions of beings in it
basically on a hard drive
and they're living in a metaverse
because why would you want to have why
would you want to be biological
you know what I mean now you have to
carry life support
I don't think it has any of that
I think it's just engines
you know
badass [ __ ] and I think a lot of it
might be in another dimension
you know so if you can build a machine
where some of it's in another dimension
feel like that means you don't need fuel
and it's got some kind of a
not a digital computer but probably
crossed in digital and [ __ ]
um uh Quantum computation going on in
there that way they feel like they're
real you can store a soul in it and
they're living in a heaven like
Multiverse or excuse metaverse so
they're in their own world
so they don't need to carry anything
with them they can be in any world they
want they can all communicate with each
other so it's kind of like heaven
and they can probably talk in between
ships they might have more than one of
them if that's what we want to call it
but I don't think it's biological
and they're just extremely ancient and
intelligent
almost kind of god-like so probably
something kind of like the monolith out
of that 2001 movie
but there's many of them in there
and I think they just
sometimes you know I think that
particular case I think you just come by
and allowing people to see them
and they're just looking
they're in their little metaverse if
anybody wants to look out they can look
out
maybe they even maybe they even feel
like they're there they might feel like
they're the ship flying through the
through this through the air you know so
I imagine it's probably not just visual
it's tactile and
so it's probably a really good
state of being that they're in you know
what I mean it's not like you've got VR
goggles on or you're in a computer you
probably feel like you're in a in a real
three-dimensional heaven-like realm that
responds to whatever you want
or you feel like you're flying through
space like you're the ship you know
and you can probably see what other
ships are doing and feel like you're
over there if you want to too so it's
probably like a big Network they're
probably billions of years old you know
they're not
they don't have to eat or anything so
there's no metabolism going on they live
forever something super what's that what
fun is that some kind of super
some kind of well they probably eat in
their metaverse but it's just
kind of like an illusion you know but it
feels real
so they probably you know because
why would you want to carry a body with
you
you want it you want to be immortal yeah
so that's probably what it is
so if you think you're gonna go in there
and walk through hallways and go into
rooms it's probably not in that ship
okay you know probed there's nothing
there yeah how much there's nothing
there
there's probably no atmosphere in it or
anything you know just open to space
make more sense to me so I was gonna ask
him what I would do if I saw one I'm not
really sure actually
um I'd probably be like really shocked I
guess I don't think like if it came down
right I'd probably like nope right the
[ __ ] out of there like yeah I'm just
gonna be over here for a second because
you don't know I mean they could like
pop out with a rigger okay what's she
doing I said look at this and she looked
at me like you're talking about me she
knows what I'm talking about hi small
land on her back doing this [ __ ]
zoning out now huh we're talking about
you yeah we're talking about yeah
whenever you do the voice she's like you
guys like stop yeah if you start
whispering she knows you're talking
about her
talking about me Blair day dude said the
Phoenix Lights was done for the Crustle
sauce was the first he was the first one
to report it yeah that's like first one
that like cracks me up that fact he
didn't know what it was he thought well
a lot of people did it saw something up
and up ahead lights he reported him he
says I don't know what those are but
something in the air
and they said okay Roger and that was it
and then later on you hurt Russell
turned out later he was he was the first
dude to report the Phoenix Lights
that's so awesome that's my favorite
part of that story and it's like he was
the first one yeah Slicer in a crust
[Laughter]
that's like so awesome
uh he says for the for the Crustle on
the Jonathan Ross show he actually gave
an account of his sighting yeah I was as
shocked as the rest of the UK about that
yeah
that was a real thing
I saw interviews yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ] that was but a lot of people
saw that yeah the uh
what do you call it
um
I got links to the original Art Bell
reports coming in
like Art Bell was I think he was on air
when it was coming he says they're
seeing something over there now and then
uh then in a couple episodes a couple
weeks later they had Witnesses saying
what they saw
and uh that went on for several months
you can find it in the Art Bell archives
but uh just you know it's not a lot of
detail but just any uh but the governor
saw it and everything five Simon didn't
but they did they couldn't do anything
and they tried to report it to the
federal government and they were like
yeah we can't do anything about it yeah
what do you want us to do yeah that's
what I mean that's why I don't think I
would report it to be honest I mean
unless I thought that it was like
dangerous like unless I thought that it
was something that needed to be reported
like that somebody could do something
about but other than that like why would
you report it and there was supposed to
be a federal response from the there was
a an Air Force air Air Field there and
they evidently sent up some Jets but
then they wouldn't talk afterwards
about anything
there's just there's no telling what it
was well it was extraterrestrial but I
don't know why it was people that saw it
said that whatever it was it was going
slowly over populated areas
to be seen
and I wasn't hiding it was [ __ ]
several miles when typically like I said
it was the let's [ __ ] with the
earthlings parade yeah like they do
the only thing I've ever seen anomalous
and I think I've told this story before
that I don't I don't necessarily think
it was a UFO
but I was driving this was when I lived
in Daytona still so this is probably
like I don't know 12 13 years ago
and I used to work the night shift so I
used to work 5 p.m till 2 A.M
and I was driving back to work from my
lunch break because I only lived a
couple miles away
and I saw in the sky it was probably
7 30 8 P.M something like that and I saw
something in this guy that looked like a
big Fireball
and that's initially what I thought it
was first thing I thought it was was a
plane exploded that's the first thing I
thought and then like when it was coming
close I thought to myself oh [ __ ] that's
a dinosaur killer that was the second
thing I thought because I had just read
like not too long before I had just read
that book who the [ __ ] wrote that that
astronomer wrote it it's called Death
from disguise and it was kind of like
all the [ __ ] that could fall on the
earth and like kill us and I mean like
gamma rays and stuff like that and so I
had just read that like a month before
literally and then like I said I'm
looking up in this guy going well
there there it is because that if I said
if that is a [ __ ] asteroid then that
is by far big enough to like wipe out
and if it's that close like I said
that's the dinosaur killer where we're
in trouble so I was just so I get back
to work and I was like what the [ __ ] did
you guys see that and they didn't know
what I was talking about and then I went
online and like tried to see if anybody
else had reported it but I didn't see
anybody else reporting it so I don't
really know
it's a meteor
that's kind of what I thought I thought
it was an asteroid but like I said it
was big it was so big that it scared me
and I said oh my God like we're going
the way of the dinosaurs I literally
thought that maybe it was the
perspective it was probably coming right
at you it probably was I mean the first
thing I thought was I thought a plane
had exploded like a plane blew up in the
air that was the first thing I thought
but then after that because I was
thinking about that Phil plate that's
that guy's name
um that astronomer that that wrote that
book I was like so I just read that book
so I was like oh [ __ ]
that's our [ __ ] that's the asteroid
right there like we're we're gonna go is
it as big as the Moon
um well that depends because the Moon
looks like a different size like
depending on your perspective you're
holding it out
um yes I guess that I guess so yeah yeah
you can think that the Moon is pretty
big but it's not I think it's about the
size of a dime
it was about that big maybe a little bit
bigger but it definitely looked like a
fireball that's what it looked like
probably just got down kind of close you
didn't hear it though no I didn't hear
anything I mean it was like in the sky
was driving like on the road and it was
like up there like in the sky you know
what I mean and it was like and it was
big enough that it scared me I said if
that's an asteroid we're [ __ ] so you
know
he said I spoke one time to Travis
Walton
looked dude in the eyes he said I don't
know what what it was but I was taken
aboard he believed the energy blast
received was a reason fix him up drop
him off yeah that's yeah we did a show
about traps one like a long time ago too
I'm not really sure like what happened
there I don't think that he was taking
on an alien ship but I think that he
believes he was taken on an alien ship
but those are two completely different
things though
Fire in the Sky is a good movie though
yeah those guys passed lie detector
tests they did but some people have come
forward and says yeah but depending on
what the lie detector test is and who's
given the test
you know what I mean well there's a
reason they're not admissible in court
really like the only thing they use them
for is eliminating people usually and I
don't even think they should do that
because they're pretty easy to get
around I don't know if I'd say easy but
it's you know it's not that hard to get
around them also if the guy's given the
test if he's sympathetic to the case
then so he can he then he might read it
in a particular way he can he can he can
show his own Spin and spin on it that's
true yeah that's true all right are you
ready to wrap it up yeah you have
anything else you would like to say
about the Lonnie Zamora case no Zach
says you know I don't think I've ever
seen a decent alien abduction horror
movie
yeah they're not I mean I don't know if
it's just me because I'm not really into
aliens as bad guys I mean other there's
exceptions of course like alien and
stuff like that but I don't know I kind
of feel like there's not what kind of
Whitley strieber's movie comedian I was
actually and that interview I did the
other day just for walking in it she
asked me about that because she was
asking me about how dare you
I think that's where the whole anal
probe joke came from Christopher
Walker's booty and he looks at the end
he goes how dare you yeah how dare he
was very offended that they had put some
[ __ ] up his booty well and they think of
it and it was the funniest thing about
it too was that it was like one of those
wall mounted vacuums like it came out
the wall I'm like they have the anal
program thing just like right there in
the how convenient that's very just suck
up in somebody's ass
gonna Hoover you out oh my God so funny
like I said if you haven't seen
communion
I read the book a long time ago
um and I remember thinking he really
believes this all right
um but the movie is
batshit insane it's like it's a weird
weird movie but I think like that's the
best scene is like for real like
Christopher Walken gets anal probed and
he gets
and just his reaction to it is just like
it's [ __ ] priceless I just can't even
I can't even I can't imagine
the sum total of decisions that came
together like that made that movie turn
out the way it did it's it's really
something
Jeff yard said damn just tuned in yeah
sorry yeah we've been on for a while
we've been on front was two and a half
hours
uh Zach said by the way I still think
you guys should do a cursed Film
Production show yeah um I put it in the
poll for next week but we'll see if
anybody votes for that I did put that
topic in the poll for next I think I did
I'm pretty sure I did because usually
like I'm usually like a week ahead on
the polls you know what I mean
because the polls are go up like on
Friday morning so if you're a patron
then the poll will go up on Friday
morning
at 10 A.M uh Eastern Standard Time and
you can vote on whatever the topic for
the next one is
yeah so yeah that's where we're talking
about communion
um
I don't know man
I'm a big skeptic of I'm not necessarily
a skeptic of like aliens like I think
there's probably got to be aliens out
there somewhere because it's a big
[ __ ] Universe you know
but them having come here
that's another thing yeah there are a
couple of credible reports of like UFOs
or like something that's probably you
know alien ships or like whatever okay
but people that actually claim that
aliens like took them into their ships
and like stuck stuff up their butts or
like put you know chips under their skin
or something like that or had babies
with them and [ __ ] like that I think
those people are just crazy people I
don't think there's because like I said
if there was aliens why the [ __ ] would
they do that I have no need for that
they they would have no need to do
they're Interstellar man their genetic
science is [ __ ] through the roof they
just need a single cell out of you and
you a little bit of DNA and it like I
said if they if they wanted your DNA all
they have to do is like get a tissue out
of your garbage can they don't need to
like [ __ ] stick stuff up your butt or
nothing like that yeah [ __ ] man they
don't even need like a like a swab out
of the inside of your cheek like they do
on the DNA test James Knapp said Travis
Walton was episode 86 for anyone
wondering gosh was it that long ago yeah
and I think we did I think we did a
movie review on Fire in the Sky too
didn't we and I think we maybe talked
about the Travis Wall in case it's good
as well the movie's good like I said
it's irregardless of whether the case is
real or not it's actually still like a
really good movie but honestly yeah now
that you mention it there's not really a
lot of really good alien abduction
movies well because like I said to me I
can't get past
yeah I can't get past like the I can't
suspend my disbelief because it just
seems like so he's full of [ __ ] though
there is a really good Alien Abduction
movie
Close Encounters of the Third Kind is an
alien abduction yeah but that's not
scary no because they're friendly we're
so he said horror movies oh horror movie
yeah yeah close encounters movie Close
Encounters is one of the best UFO I
think it is the best UFO movie yeah I
mean yeah I love Close Encounters but
it's not a horror movie they're friendly
aliens he's like yeah well you don't
know though because there's a lot of
suspense the first time you see it you
think maybe it is something sinister
yeah yeah don't you remember yeah I did
when you were a kid you're a guy kind of
scared of this thing it took that kid
yeah the [ __ ] planes back there's all
kinds of weird [ __ ] had happened and
these mysterious groups have appeared
and people were [ __ ] being knocked
out remember that and they had [ __ ]
dead animals laying everywhere and they
said there was a gas attack that was a
nerve agent or [ __ ] what was it that
they had to have a cover story to get
everybody out of the area
yeah you don't remember that part do you
yeah I remember that okay yeah
but I'm just saying that in in the
aggregate that it's not a horror movie
no that's what I'm saying no but when I
was a kid it was kind of still scary
yeah the first part of it was gonna
carry actually the second part too when
it was coming down and the aliens came
out to be honest there's really I'm
trying to think like there's a lot of
horror movies that are based around
aliens like alien attacks and stuff like
that but there's not a lot of them that
are specifically alien abduction movies
yeah isn't that interesting yeah that's
something I hadn't really thought of
before
and the fact that I can't really think
of any other ones other than fire in the
sky and that's based on a true story
you know yeah I don't know yeah okay
[Laughter]
whatever I just can't talk anymore about
it yeah whatever yeah all right so we're
gonna wrap it up I guess
uh because we've been going for two and
a half hours and we're done with the
case
so uh yeah so the next show is gonna be
Friday and that'll be the side track
show so that should be fun might be
another uh pre-game we might get a
mannequins after yeah not really sure
uh but yeah you are right yeah okay
we've been on for two and a half hours I
know but it's like you're just kind of
oh okay
what you gonna make I already made it we
got that Thai food oh that's right yeah
yeah I want some more of that that stuff
was good Dark Skies was all right I
think oh yeah that's right that's right
yeah that one was okay okay so that's so
there's more than one all right so we'll
be back uh Friday night for the side
track show thank you everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good night